And to the Republic, for which it stands, indivisible, justice for all.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Representative Michael Boze of EPIC.
As chair of the House Science, Technology, and Energy Committee, I find that due to the state of emergency declared by the governor as a result of the COVID-19 pandemic and in accordance with House Rule 67 and the governor's Emergency Order Number 12 pursuant to Executive Order 2020-04, this public body is authorized to meet electronically.
This is a public hearing of bills referred to the Science, Technology, and Energy Committee.
Executive session on pending legislation may be held at any time.
Please note that there is no physical location for members of the public to observe and listen contemporaneously to this meeting.
However, in accordance with the emergency order, I am confirming that all members of the committee and select legislative staff have the ability to communicate contemporaneously during this meeting through the Zoom electronic meeting platform, and the public has access to contemporaneously listen and, if necessary, participate in this meeting by the Zoom platform or by telephone.
All necessary access information has been made available in the House calendar and through the electronic calendar on the general court website.
The notice for this meeting complies with House Rules and RSA 91-A.
Anyone who has a problem accessing the meeting should call 271-3600 or email hcs at ledge.state.nh.us.
In the event the public is unable to access the meeting, the meeting will be adjourned and rescheduled.
I want to introduce the staff that are on the meeting assisting us today, Jennifer Foer, committee researcher.
Please note, all votes that are taken during this meeting shall be done by roll call vote.
And we will start the meeting by taking roll call attendance.
When each member states their presence, please also state whether there is anyone in the room with you during this meeting which is required under the right to know law.
And for the members who are in the room this morning, when you acknowledge the call of the roll, indicate that you are in the committee room.
I now call on the acting clerk, Murder to call the roll.
Morning everybody.
Representative Thomas here in the committee room.
Representative Harrington.
I'm at home with my wife and my dog.
Representative Daughter.
Here in the committee room.
Representative Myrna.
Here.
Representative Homoluck.
Here in the committee room.
Representative Fresny.
Present in the committee room.
Representative Bernadette.
Here in the committee room.
Representative Kimbrills.
Present in the committee room.
Thank you.
Representative Bernadette.
Here in the committee room.
Representative Kimbrels.
Present in the committee room.
Representative Pozet.
Representative White.
Here in the committee room.
Representative Sausage.
Yes, present.
I'm at home by myself.
Representative Kelly Pitts.
At home, alone.
Representative Meehan.
At home and no one else is here in the house.
Representative Oxenham.
Present, alone in the room.
Representative Vincent.
I'm here, I'm at my home, and I'm alone at this time.
Representative McGee.
I'm home, and I'm alone in my office.
Representative McWilliams.
Present, I'm here with my husband and my father.
Cretien.
Representative Cretien.
I am here.
I'm alone in my home with my dog.
Representative Pippitav.
I'm here alone in my home.
Representative Pasha.
Here alone in my room.
And the chairman, Representative Vose.
I'm present and I'm in the committee room.
Along with me here in the committee room are representatives Bernardernardy logey reggie thomas burner nodder homola cambrils and white so welcome everybody to our our session for monday the first of february and happy febru to everyone.
Before we get to the business of the day the chair recognizes Representative Nutter.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman I'd like to make a motion to reconsider our actions on House Bill 615.
Representative Nutter makes a motion to reconsider 624, correct?
614.
Isn't that right?
We didn't vote on 614.
We voted on 624.
No, we did.
I'm sorry, I'm confused.
Okay, back up.
No, it's 624.
It's 624.
We are currently on the agenda.
I'm sorry, I'm confused.
I'm confused.
Okay, back up.
No, it's 624.
It's 624.
You are correct.
I jumped ahead of myself.
624.
Okay, so Representative Nauter has made a motion to reconsider our action on HB 624.
Representative Bernardi.
I second that motion.ernardy seconds the motion that we reconsider our action on house bill six to four this is a non this is a debatable motion but not the substance of the bill the only thing that's debatable is whether or not there is a good reason for reconsideration and And I'm told that Representative Michael Harrington, who was unable to vote last Friday, was unable to vote because he was taken out of the room because of a family emergency.
So that is adequate cause for a motion of reconsideration.
Does anyone else have any discussion of the idea of reconsideration?
Representative Callie Pitts is recognized.
I have two questions.
I have two questions, and one of them is, does this need two-thirds or does it need a simple majority?
And the second question is really more than a question.
It's really a statement.
The last thing I heard before I signed off last week troubled me so much that I'm going to mention it today.
And it was, is this the game you want to play?
And I think that that troubled me.
And I take offense at that.
I don't think anybody here, I'm going to speak for myself, not anybody else.
I do not take this as a game or else I would not be sitting here for five hours.
I would not be doing 10 hours worth of research or more.
It's not a game to me.
I take it very seriously.
And that remark offended me.
Thank you, Representative Kelly Pitts.
The answer to your question is simple majority.
The chair now recognizes Representative Somsich for a question or a comment.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I am quite surprised by this motion, and it seems to me a blatant political motion.
I can understand that situations arise where someone may not be able to vote when they're there.
If this were in the normal session in the House and you weren't in your seat, you couldn't vote, your vote just didn't count.
That's the way it is.
And I thought that we, Mr.
Chairman, you and I came to an agreement that was mutually agreeable, that would do what we intended to do with a floor amendment.
And I thought that was a genuine act of bipartisanship for change.
This reconsideration, on the other hand, is a blatant partisanship going on here.
So I'm really disappointed about that.
Okay.
Thank you, Representative Somsich.
Seeing no other hands raised.
Representative Nader.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The representative who missed the boat called me at home afterwards and he explained the situation to me and it was an emergency, a very personal matter that I'm not going to share with you.
But if I was in that situation, I would have left the room too.
It was serious.
Thank you, Representative Nutter.
I Not sure of a loose hand when I first here, but I take a chance that it was Representative Boxman.
My question has to do with the amendment.
Are we going to have an opportunity to deal with the amendment now?
Questions about the substance of the bill are not in order.
Right now, we're only debating whether to reconsider it or not.
Representative McGee.
And don't forget to get close to your microphone, please.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
That was basically the substance of my question as well which is that where we left the bill I thought when we had the vote was that we were planning to make some word changes that would make it acceptable and bipartisan and now it sounds like we're going to put Representative Harrington's vote back in and override that so that there is no bipartisanship in terms of how the language is crafted is that what i'm understanding thank you uh representative mick williams is that what i'm understanding is that what is happening we've been asked to reconsider.
Yes.
Representative Williams.
Thank you, Chair Vose.
I respectfully request a challenge on this specific motion.
My understanding is that due to Robert's rules, if you want to reconsider, you need to have a vote on the prevailing side that wishes to reconsider.
This vote was 10-10, and so I would request that staff take a look at the procedure for this because i don't believe that this is allowed thank you for that question i talked to the clerk about that this morning and because there was no prevailing side anybody can make a motion to reconsider representative thomas thank you mr chair i'd just like to make comment comment on the last comment.
We are under Mason's rules, not Robert's rules.
And in the case of committees, we do not have to be on the prevailing side to make a motion to reconsider.
Only when you're at the House session.
Thank you.
Representative Cretion is recognized for a comment.
Thank you, Chair.
I just had a question again about the amendment.
When we left it on Friday, we were told that we didn't have time to consider delaying the vote on this till today in order to leave time for an amendment.
So I'm surprised that we've decided we have time for reconsideration is that something that you can explain the explanation is that a member asked for reconsideration which is a legitimate request does anybody else need to speak doesn't appear that that's the case.
So I'll ask the clerk to call the roll.
Mr.
Chairman, I do request to speak, please.
Okay, Representative Sonsich.
Well, in light of the fact that this looks pretty bipartisan to me, I would request that Representative Harrington provide a certified letter confirming his medical emergency at home to the partisan to me, I would request that Representative Harrington provide a certified letter confirming his medical emergency at home to the committee members.
Noted.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Let's take the call on the roll.
Representative Merner, you have the floor.
On the motion, reconsider.
Representative Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Harrington.
Excuse me.
I represent you didn't don't forget to turn on your video when you vote.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
I think you can see me now daughter yes clerk yes representative homula yes representative breast Yes.
Oh, sorry, no.
I vote no.
Representative Kelly Pitts.
No.
Representative Meehan.
Representative Oxenham.
No.
Representative Vincent?
Representative McGee?
No.
Representative McWilliams?
Package coming in, Linda.
No.
Thank you.
Representative Feess?
No.
Thank you.
Representative Feachin?
No.
Representative Pimentel?
Representative Hachel?
No.
And the Chair?
Chair votes yes.
Reconsideration passes.
Reconsideration has passed, so we will now reconsider HB 624, and the chair recognizes Representative Nauter for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I move to pass on House Bill 624.
Representative Nutter moves to pass on House Bill 624.
Representative Bernardi.
I second the motion.
It has been moved and seconded that HB 624 we voted ought to pass.
Is there any discussion?
Representative Oxenam.
Yes, I'd like to move an amendment.
Do you have a written amendment from OLS?
That would not have been possible under the circumstances, now would it?
It would have been possible, but I guess you didn't do it.
We should have assumed that we'd have this change and this bill would be brought back to us in this manner?
Could it be put off until later in the day so that we have an opportunity to submit an amendment to OLS, Mr.
Chairman?
No, I don't think we have time to do that.
So we need to dispose of this matter now.
Representative Prezni, did you have a comment to make about this bill?
Thank you.
Representative Cambrils?
No comment.
Representative Samcic?
Yes, Mr.
Chairman.
I really have to object to the procedures here.
On the one hand, last time we heard that we didn't have enough time to discuss everything, and then when the vote happened and it was tied, then we decided the way to resolve it would be with a floor amendment, which I thought was a very good gesture of bipartisanship.
Now this is a blatant partisan attack on everything we've tried to build together here, and that will have repercussions later on for sure, but I don't see why an amendment that was basically supported by everybody last time would not be in order at this time, and as Representative Oxenham mentioned, there's no way we could have anticipated that we should have gotten this ready ahead of time.
So if you're gonna be blindsiding us on a regular basis, I'd like to know that now.
Thank you for that comment.
The floor amendment idea is still on the table.
Representative Callie Pitts.
Don't forget to unmute.
All I wanted to know is if the amendment was still going to be not put off to the Senate and not put off to the floor, but be able to be entertained in this committee.
know what the rules are once you move on to business and once the vote is final.
So I would ask that we ask the clerk what the procedure is on that.
And I don't think that's out of order.
Again, if I'm playing a game, then I got to know the rules.
And I think that Paul is the one that can tell us what the procedure is this.
Because once the vote is final and we've moved on to something else, is it like a football that once you pass the next play, you can't protest?
I'd like to know that and I'd like to have a definitive ruling on that.
Right easy Reagan.
Representative Harrington.
Representative Parshall.
Yes my concern over the passage of this is that it sets precedents for the future.
And that will mean that any bill will be able to be brought back again for reconsidering at an opportune time without amending it.
I just think that sets a very bad precedence that I do hope this is not the way we are moving forward to conduct business.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative Vincent.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chairman.
I was wondering if it was possible where all this Zoom is all new to us.
And I know you've laid down some ground rules.
I was wondering if it was possible if we could actually put these on paper so we can all understand what the rules are.
So then it won't be any variation or any challenges, so to speak, in the future.
Thank you.
That's a good request.
I will make sure every member of the committee gets a copy of the guidelines.
They're not rules, but I'll make sure every member of the committee gets a copy.
Representative Immantell.
Don't forget to unmute.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I strongly object to this continuing that we should not be voting to override the original vote.
Thank you.
Representative Bernardi.
I'd like to speak against the concept of this amendment and as was discussed last week the entire premise that corporations are bad and need to be punished to pay full freight and and small people are the ones who deserve $150.00.
The team is not in that argument.
We considered a bill last Friday where we heard the TUC tell us that the telephone company and the cable companies could not pay for removing a telephone pole.
They had to deal with just the urgent business of their company because they did not have the resources.
So the concept in principle that corporations have the money to pay these big unnecessary fees, I believe is fundamentally flawed and I totally reject the concept of the amendment.
Representative Rezni.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
This bill is about justice and I believe that if justice is blind and impartial, then access to justice should also be impartial.
Thank you.
everyone who has so far represented a nodder.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just wanted to reiterate that any representative has the right to ask for consideration.
So this is not something that we just made up.
Correct.
Thank you.
Anybody else in the room have a Thomas?
It appears that everybody, Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, for my question.
I would like to reiterate that Representative Dobbs is correct.
Anyone has a right to vote for reconsideration.
This has happened before in my six years in in this committee and it has happened before where certain understandings were there and then because of maybe administrative discussions afterwards the situation's changed it's not unusual but i will say that this is a central committee bill so a secret committee has the opportunity to listen to arguments for whether or not we want amendments and then there's also the opportunity for a floor amendment before the house and again there's also opportunity to reach the other side of the room to have amendments here as well so i personally feel that letting this field go as is will open up the door to lose opportunities for further discussion and is why i'm in favor of the wpp as it stands right now okay thank you representative thomas it is now 10 25.
we are 25 minutes beyond the time at which we were supposed to start our first public hearing, but we can't do so as long as we're involved in this voting process.
So I just want to alert everybody to that fact and remind them that we have a second public hearing at 11 o'clock, 1130 rather, no 11 o'clock and we'll have to start promptly on top of that is there anybody else who uh wishes to speak i can see three hand raised hands raised i'm not sure if you forgot to lower your hand from the last time or if you really want to speak if you could wave at me representative mcgee yes thank you mr chairman.
My comment actually goes directly to the time issue, which seems to be at the root cause of why we're rushing through bills and not able to express some of the issues that are really germane to our positions on those bills.
And I had sent you a note asking whether we could simply add another remote meeting during the week, because we normally do have two days a week that we would meet to get through our bills because this time constraint is based on when the bills have to be out of committee and the fact that we can only meet once a week and I just wanted you to know that eDNA is meeting twice a week there is not it's an I think it's an arbitrary and artificial constraint that we are unable to have more than one day a week for meetings.
And it is leading to all of these other problems.
So I would ask you to reconsider the note that I sent you and actually discuss how it is that other committees are actually able to meet multiple times a week when you basically told us that that was not possible.
Thank you.
Thank you for the question, Representative.
There are some smaller committees in the House like Fish and Game, Veterans Affairs, a couple of other small committees that don't have a lot of business to conduct during the course of a session matter of fact fish and game was hoping to dispose of all six of their bills in one day so if that should happen we've been told by house leadership that we may be able to have a second meeting in a week.
It would use the same format as the meetings we're conducting right now, but we may get at least one and maybe more weeks where we can have multiple meetings if necessary.
But if we don't put that on the schedule, then we're going to continue to run into the problem that we're having now, which is that we're rushing through things that require additional consideration and not actually completing our job before we pass them off.
Well, we have to deal with the, we have to play the hand we're dealt.
Okay, Representative Oxen.
I want to strongly protest the notion that the hearing on my bill is being truncated because of this issue.
I think that the only fair thing is to move every hearing forward starting at the time after which this vote is concluded.
Okay, thank you.
Seeing no other representative Homolot.
Thank you, Chair.
I just want to comment that I actually agree with Representative Bernardi and Representative, I'm sorry, I'm so bad to say your name.
All right.
Thanks.
I want to say that one of the things that we heard in testimony was the difficulties that the utilities have quite frankly in doing anything above and beyond public what they provide to the public.
testimony was the difficulties that the utilities have quite frankly in doing anything above and beyond public what they provide to the public in many instances and I do think it is appropriate to lower the fees for this particular with this bill tries to do to lower the fees but I do think it's important that it lowers the fees for consumers and it lowers the fees for those businesses and utilities as well.
So I think it is an appropriate as is and thank you very much.
Thank you, Representative.
Seeing no other hands raised for discussion, I'm going to call the vote and ask the clerk, the acting to read the roll call to clarify what we're going on oh okay we're voting on a motion of ought to pass on hb 624.
on the motion of ought to pass on 624.
Representative Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Harrington.
Representative Nauta.
Yes.
Representative Murner.
Representative Homola.
Yes.
Representative Bresni.
Representative Bernadette.
Yes.
Representative Kimbrose.
Representative Brezny.
Yes.
Representative Bernadette.
Representative Kimbrows.
Yes.
Representative Closet.
Representative White.
Yes.
Representative Somsich.
No.
Representative Kelly Pitts.
Unmute, Jackie.
No.
going to say.
Representative Mann.
No.
Representative Oxenham.
Representative Vincent.
No.
Representative Oxenham?
Representative Vincent?
No.
Representative McGee?
Representative McWilliams?
No.
Representative Creechin?
Representative Pimentel?
No.
Thank you.
no representative pimentel representative pimentel you're muted mr pin pinitel and i would suggest that uh represent pimentel needs to show his video right where is he perhaps he was called away might have been an emergency represented partial no Representative Paschal?
No.
And the chair?
Representative votes.
Chair votes yes.
So with one not voting, the vote is 11 to 9.
Okay.
So the motion to opt to pass on HB 624 passes 11 to 9.
Will there be a minority report, Representative Sausage?
Yes, there will be.
I will write that report.
Thank you.
And I also request a right to speak on a motion.
What motion is that?
I would like to move to reconsider 624.
more.
Well, since we already reconsidered that, I don't see a need to reconsider it again.
Motions in order.
Yep.
We were just told any representative can make that motion, so I'm making it.
All right.
I'll let you make it, but you've got to make a solid case for allowing a reconsideration.
So Representative Somsich has moved reconsideration.
Is there a second?
Second.
It's moved and seconded that we reconsider HB 6224.
Is there any discussion on the motion to reconsider?
Yes.
Representative Callie-Pitts.
I was just informed that there is somebody in OLS who can draft an amendment now.
And my confusion, Representative, Mr.
Chairman, is that I wouldn't know how to get a paper amendment.
But there is somebody in OLS who could draft a friendly amendment, the one we all agreed on yesterday, and they could do it right now.
And that was told to me by the clerk.
So that is the reason that I would like to reconsider to get that friendly amendment drafted.
I just spoke to Paul, and my understanding is once the bill leaves the committee, and I don't know how it leaves the committee either, that an amendment can only be filed on the floor.
So I would hope that we could reconsider and then hold this bill until OLS gets that amendment.
And it should only take them, you know, well, I can't speak for them, but they can do it right now.
Thank you.
Representative Sausage.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The reason I'm also making this motion is because I just heard a couple of comments from at least three representatives in the conference room who gave impressions to me that maybe they had a different take on this bill than I did.
I was very much in favor of the sentiment expressed by Representative Harrington last time, how ordinary residents who have an issue with the Site Evaluation Committee project should be able to get a declaratory decision for a small fee.
And we're going to have a question.
And we be able to get a declaratory decision for a small fee.
And it was also mentioned that in previous years, ordinary residents didn't have to pay anything, but businesses and corporations interested in the project were required to pay this fee.
Now I'm hearing we should reduce the fee for everybody, which seems to me to go against the sentiment of the bill originally stated.
So I'm a little confused and maybe other representatives are also confused and that's why I'm asking for reconsideration.
Thank you, Representative Vincent.
Thanks again, Mr.
Chairman.
I have a point of clarification.
Thank you, Representative Vincent.
Thanks again, Mr.
Chairman.
I have a point of clarification.
So if I'm sitting in the conference room, everything only applies to Zoom, to people that are on Zoom, correct?
Meaning if I wanted to do a blue card, I'm not going to file it through the website.
I'm going to be there to file it.
And it's important to me because if I was there right now, I could give an amendment to you, correct?
Am I correct with saying that?
No, the same rules apply to everyone.
So to actually have to be able to speak in for or against something that comes to testimony, then we have to file through the website, correct?
Well, no, not if you're a member of the committee, but if you're an outside member, yes, if you want to speak, you have to file through the...
Okay, thank you.
Thank you for that clarification.
Representative Voxen.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chairman.
We were informed on Friday that the SEC is cash strapped.
And the only way in which it's able to finance any of its necessary operations is through the collection of these fees.
We were further informed that we went through the discussion about making sure that the original concept of the SAC, which is to allow the public access to the process without undue harm and making every possible availability to them to be able to be part of that process.
And suddenly we're now being told, oh, it's going to be wide open for corporations as well.
This actually is a way of demolishing the, destroying the SEC as an institution, making it incapable of functioning.
And if that is your intent, then I think that you should be open about that rather than trying to do it through this backdoor measure.
Thank you for your comment.
I don't know how closely you were listening the other day, but I was somewhat shocked to learn that the SEC gets $500,000 a year from the general fund.
So to characterize them as being poor, cash starved, I think is a mischaracterization.
Representative Pimentel.
We need to have more information before we can vote on this bill because that is not my understanding of the testimony.
I recognize Representative Pimentel.
Sorry Mr.
Chairman for my quick departure.
I was having smelling smoke.
I had to go deal with my wood stove downstairs but everything is fine now.
I'm glad you're safe.
Okay, so everyone who has shown an interest in speaking on this motion to reconsider has spoken.
So let's call the roll and vote on reconsideration of HB 624.
On the reconsideration of 624.
Motion was made by Mr.
Chairman.
Who's who's uh okay.
Nevermind.
Representative Thomas.
No.
Representative Harrington.
Representative Noada.
No.
Representative Myrna.
Representative Holot.
No.
Representative Bresni.
Representative Bernadette.
No.
Representative Kembrils.
Representative Jose.
No.
Representative White.
Representative Sausage.
Yes.
Representative Callie Pitts?
Representative Meehan?
Yes.
Representative Oxenham?
Representative Vincent?
Yes.
Representative McGee?
mcwilliams yes representative crescent yes please representative pimontale yes representative yes Vose?
Vose votes no.
Chairman, point of order.
Reconsideration fails 11 to 10.
Okay, reconsideration of HB 624 has failed by a vote of 11 to 10.
Who asked for a point of order?
I did.
Representative Douglas Thomas should be on video when he votes.
He's right there.
Representative Harrington is on video.
No, Douglas Thomas.
He's in the room.
He's right there.
Oh, he's in the room.
I see his name on here as well.
My apology then.
His name appears blank on my Zoom.
All right, thank you.
All right, now that that matter has been disposed of at the relatively late hour of 1042, I'd like to open the public hearing on HB 394, a bill establishing the commission to study the short and long-term impacts of pending national and regional carbon pricing mechanisms on New Hampshire's residents, agriculture, wildlife, and natural resources-based tourism sector and commercial enterprises.
And I ask the prime sponsor of the bill, Representative Oxenham, to introduce the bill, please.
Thank you.
Mr.
Chair, before my five minutes opens, I would like a clarification on how this hearing is going to be conducted.
Are we being held to 18 minutes on this matter?
I don't think 18 minutes is realistic.
What I will do is at 11 o'clock I will open the public hearing on the next bill, which is HB 410, I believe.
And then we'll recess that hearing immediately.
We have five people who have signed up to speak on this bill.
So hopefully we can get through those five speakers in relatively short order.
Thank you and proceed, Representative Oxenam.
And don't forget to unmute.
Thank you.
Over the last 12 months of this pandemic, we learned that we may have to deal with catastrophes that come upon us unawares.
We also recognize that there is a catastrophe that we are currently involved in and which is looming larger as time goes on and that we must deal with it as we have with the COVID crisis by changing our behavior, by innovating and rising to the challenge.
During the past year, we saw a planet literally on fire from Australia to California to Siberia.
Droughts that produce millions of climate refugees, unprecedented heavy precipitation events and floods with costs and human lives and infrastructure damage in the trillions of dollars.
We know we must take action to avoid leaving behind an unlivable planet with an erratic climate that will no longer support human civilization.
Conservative estimates by the world's climate scientists state that to achieve climate stabilization and avoid cataclysmic changes, emissions of CO2 and other greenhouse gases must be brought down to at least 80 to 95 percent below 1990 levels by 2050.
This won't be easy and it won't be cheap, but we have options.
And the best option, according to economists, is putting a price on carbon emissions.
Currently, the environmental health and social costs of carbon emissions are not included in carbon prices.
These are treated as externalized costs that are borne directly and indirectly by Americans in their impaired health and increased morbidity and mortality.
There's no such thing as a free market when it comes to energy.
It's rife with monopolies, regulatory regimes, asymmetric information, and asymmetric power.
When it comes to fossil fuels, there are dozens of direct and indirect subsidies, which economists call externalities, buried in the tax code or in plain view.
And they all come with costs, tens of billions of dollars annually.
These externalities distort the economic calculus of producers and consumers, be they households, businesses, or government entities.
In short, they distort the market, burden society, and the rest of the economy.
Nobody pays the true price of carbon.
Conservative estimates put direct subsidies annually at $20 billion a year.
For economists, the value of a pricing system lies in its ability to capture all the costs associated with that particular good.
Fossil fuel externalities, including social costs, environmental costs, and health costs, are not being borne by those imposing them.
They're being borne by the rest of us.
Addressing those externalities could save taxpayers billions of dollars in societal costs while improving health and the quality of life.
National and regional carbon pricing systems are being developed as we speak, carbon fee and dividend in particular.
It can protect low and middle income citizens from the economic impacts of rising prices and fees.
It can deliver dividends directly to every person in the country if it's a national regime or regionally if that is the way that it is being imposed.
Because low and moderate income earners spend less than they receive out of these dividend payments, actually imposing carbon fees spurs spending and leads to direct economic growth.
And this has been demonstrated around the world in countries where it's been developed.
Carbon pricing spurs market-driven innovation and market efficiencies, which will reduce harmful pollution and leave a healthier, more stable, and more prosperous nation for future generations.
In just 12 years, it is predicted that America's CO2 emissions can be reduced by 40 percent.
No other method has this possible efficacy.
So if it's such a great idea, why do we need a study committee?
Carbon pricing is coming.
It's the most efficient and the most cost-effective way for us to mitigate the dangers associated with unbridled climate change.
In the last three years, all our fellow states in the ISO region have put forward legislation with carbon pricing.
Often, their actions are tied to the actions in neighboring states.
ISO New England itself supports carbon pricing and has called on the states to work together.
Nationally, we see a number of moves from the Biden administration, and we've also seen the National Chamber of Commerce in just this last week endorsing carbon pricing.
New Hampshire needs to be prepared for what's coming.
We need to be at the table so that our lack of fossil fuel production facilities does not leave us out of the loop when others are reaching their decisions.
We need to be proactive in safeguarding the economic interests of New Hampshire businesses and residents.
We need a seat at the table, and to get there, we need to prepare.
Please support this bill.
Thank you, Representative Oxenham.
Are there any questions for the representative?
Representative Homola?
Yes, Chair.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative Oxenham for providing this information.
I have just one question.
Since the U.S.
carbon emissions have come down since 2005 steadily, what would be the impetus for this bill?
In the interest of time, I'm not going to reiterate the remarks that I've made.
We have a number of other speakers who will be providing information on that point.
So I can't give you anything further at this time representative okay representative Somsich thank you Mr.
Chairman and thank you Reverend Oxenham for taking my question do I I understand from my knowledge of how this kind of proposal came about, is it not true or am I correct in assuming that this was actually a bipartisan proposal for carbon pricing and that in fact there is a lot of consensus on both sides of the political spectrum that carbon pricing is the best market mechanism to do it.
Correct.
Yes, I believe you're referring to one particular bill that's currently in Congress, which has strong bipartisan buy-in.
And as you'll hear from other speakers, economists from both sides, former secretaries and treasurer from Republican administrations and Democratic administrations, it's very strongly bipartisan support.
Thank you very much.
Representative Harrington.
Yes, Mr.
Chairman.
This is actually a question for the chair.
Since this is a commission, and I know we've had discussions on this in the past with study committees and commissions, that there was going to be a push to retain those bills.
And I realized that the representative put an awful lot of work into this, and she certainly should have her day to do it.
But if we're going to retain the bills and come back again with these next year, wouldn't it be better to address the bill at that time, if that's the intent of where we're heading with these commissions and study committees?
Not picking on this one in particular, but just that seems to be a general policy.
Well, you raise a good point, Representative Harrington.
If we do anything with this bill, it would be to retain it.
So we'll have plenty of time to discuss the bill in the fall.
But if people want to discuss it now, we can.
I won't cut them off.
Let's put it that way.
Representative McGee, you're recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
My question was actually pertaining to the same thing.
I wanted to ask Representative Oxenham, since we're being told that study commissions and committees will be retained for time constraints again, which I feel are self-imposed and not necessarily, but that's an editorial thing.
Can you give us the reason why this particular commission's work should not be delayed because I think that would be a relevant bit of information for us.
We have two options here today.
We can retain the bill as was suggested by the chair as the standard process for dealing with study committees and study commissions.
There's also an option for an ITL.
And I must say, after this morning's discussions, I feel that this bill is in threat of not being retained, despite those assurances.
So I feel that we need to have the discussion at this time so that people understand, first and foremost, the nature of the threat that we face.
Secondly, the fact that there is an option on the table to do this, whether New Hampshire is present or not.
And this commission is all about making it possible for New Hampshire to have a voice and be represented as those discussions go forward.
Thank you.
Next up would be, oh, I see no more hands actually.
So I thank you representative oxenham for introducing the bill and i will now call on our next speaker who would be the honorable marge shepherdsson so if she could be elevated from attendee or allowed to speak I'd like to turn the floor over to former representative Shepperson.
Okay, I figured it out.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And thank you to the members of ST&E for holding this hearing.
I urge you to pass HB 394 and establish a commission to study the effects a carbon fee would have on the citizens and businesses of New Hampshire.
Polls have shown that 70% of people want action on climate change.
As you have heard, a carbon fee and dividend program would address the problem by reducing carbon emissions greatly.
This plan has been endorsed by many citizens and groups around the country, most recently by the U.S.
Chamber of Commerce, which now says it supports, quote, durable climate policy and a market-based approach to accelerate greenhouse gas emissions reductions across the U.S.
economy, unquote.
They prefer the market over regulation because it is least cost and it doesn't grow government.
Citizens across New Hampshire are endorsing carbon pricing, as evidenced by the 28 towns that passed a resolution to that effect last year, and the numerous new towns that will consider it this year.
I expect the number to more than double.
A growing number of faith communities have endorsed it as well.
Last year, led by churches in New Hampshire, the United Church of Christ endorsed it at their national synod, and they represent 5,000 churches across the country.
They join 130 other faith groups from Christian, Jewish, Muslim, Buddhist, and Quaker backgrounds around the country.
Businesses are also endorsing it more each day.
How do we know what effect carbon pricing would have on our state?
That's what this bill is about.
What effect on our businesses, such as tourism, forestry, farming, maple syrup production, skiing?
We know this is coming in the near future, and you as legislators have the opportunity to plan for it.
You can help position our state to be ready, ready to create new jobs, ready to benefit from investments in renewable energy infrastructure.
Please help New Hampshire lead the way by figuring out how carbon pricing will affect us and what we can do to take advantage of this new reality.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative, former Representative Shepperson.
Thanks for being here today.
We appreciate having a chance to interact with you.
Always good to see you.
Are there any questions for Ms.
Shepperson?
How about Representative McGee?
I'm sorry Mr.
Chair, I believe my hand was up from the prior question.
Oh, no problem.
Just a reminder to everybody, once you're finished speaking, if you could lower your hand so that it doesn't appear that you're asking me to speak again.
Okay, looking around the room, I see no hands raised.
I see no hands raised on Zoom.
So we'll move on to our next speaker.
Excuse me, Mr.
Chairman.
My hand is raised.
Well, it wasn't a second ago when I looked at the screen.
You got me, Representative Sopsich.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chairman.
I have a question for Ms.
Shepparton.
So I understand you're mentioning that these organizations, these religious organizations, are involved in this effort.
Could you tell me what their main motivation is, why they're getting behind this effort?
Certainly, Representative.
They're behind it because they feel they have a moral obligation to help protect the earth, to conserve the natural world, and that's under great threat from climate change.
They also feel it's a social justice issue because communities of color are affected more than others, often living near coal power plants, for example, and having higher rates of asthma and other illnesses, cancer.
So we feel it's both a social issue and environmental justice issue.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Seeing no more hands raised, I will comment on our next speaker.
It's 11 o'clock, Mr.
Chairman.
Say again?
It's 11 o'clock.
Were you going to open the other hearing and then return to this one?
Yes.
Was that the process you suggested?
So I'm going to now open the public hearing on HB 410 and immediately recess that hearing and we will return to it as soon as we get the opportunity.
Thank you.
on HB 410 and immediately recess that hearing and we will return to it as soon as we get the opportunity.
But next, we will hear from Mr.
Sam Duan, who is a member of the public representing himself.
Mr.
Duan, you are recognized to speak.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairan, you are recognized to speak.
Chair.
So hi, my name is Sam Duan.
I'm an alum from Derryfield School in Manchester and currently a freshman at Boston University studying political science and philosophy.
And I speak on behalf of myself today based on my observations in support of HB 394.
So I will start with a little bit of a story about myself.
I'm originally from China.
In the first five years or so of my life, I grew up on my grandparents' farm in a rural town in the midst of acres and acres of wheat and rice in the company of chicken sparrows and pigs and other critters whose names I don't even know.
And there was a little creek in front of my grandparents' house.
And every summer I would go with my uncle and cousins and catch little fishes in it.
Then I moved to the city, went to school.
My dad started a business when I was 10, et cetera, et cetera.
And a few years ago when I visited my grandparents, again, things were different.
A new chemical plant opened a few kilometers down the street.
The sky now took on a permanently hazy color.
The air had a density to it and it scratched your throat if you stayed outside for more than 10 or so minutes.
Domestic animals were no longer allowed out.
The wild animals, if you could see them, now had a sickly look to them.
The little creek in front of my grandparents' house was now black with a smell of rubber, petroleum, and naphtha.
The story continued when I moved to New Hampshire.
One of the first things I learned to do when I moved here was skiing, obviously, but every year the weather became wackier and wackier.
Later snow, less snow, and further up north I have to go to ski and less Massachusetts people on the highways, which was good news for me, but probably not for ski mountains.
And this wackiness peaks on those past years, 60 degrees and raining Christmas in southern New Hampshire.
But on the other side of the coin is my dad and his business.
He's involved in wholesale transportation of manufactured goods, which we now know as a whole contributes greatly to the pollution that we face.
So suddenly it seemed that if I'm going to fight for my thorough-esque aspirations, I'd be tossing my bread and butter on the floor and stomping on it.
But carbon pricing elegantly reconciles this conflict of interest.
Tweaking the markets against pollution was something I never thought about.
For me, the biggest advantage of carbon pricing is that it's simple and predictable.
My dad would know to invest in electric trucks if he clearly understands that diesel trucks will become more expensive in the next five years.
An expenditure in the first few years, maybe, but that would keep us afloat for the foreseeable future.
If this can happen to wholesale transportation, it can happen to any business.
The most major drawback, I think, of carbon pricing is that it does not directly address pollution in an obvious way.
Emphasis on the word obvious, which I think is also why it is not as popular of a policy compared to some other ones in mass media.
But that is exactly why we need a study commission to provide a more scientific, less emotional, and more trustworthy understanding of government pricing.
And not far from where I live in Southern New Hampshire, there is a sugar shack and their maple syrup is the hands-down best maple syrup I've ever had.
Every morning, we'll have a cup of coffee or tea with exactly one teaspoon of maple syrup in it.
And if we do nothing in a decade or two, sugar maple will no longer grow on that latitude and I would have to set my morning tea tax to Canada instead.
And hence I support HB 394.
Thank you.
Thank you, we appreciate that.
Any questions for Mr.
Duan?
Representative McGee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Mr.
Dewan, for your testimony.
I'm assuming that would be Ben's sugar shack in southern New Hampshire?
No, I'm not going to make any, what do Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Actually, my question was around, you talked about the elegance of the solution in your testimony.
And I think maybe you want, I'd like to hear you say a little bit more about that.
Because when I got involved with looking at carbon pricing in the last session, what was nice about it was the cash back portion, which is the concept that although the polluters get charged for the pollution they cause so that they're no longer externalizing those costs, the benefits go to the rate payers so that the increasing cost doesn't end up burdening them as we move away from dirtier fuels.
So you mentioned the elegance, but I think, I don't know if you really said a lot about that piece of it.
So could you say a little more?
Oh, I actually, I actually like that a lot because like my parents' business, for example, we started out very small, which I think is, you know, a common theme here in New Hampshire.
And I think a dividend would actually benefit smaller businesses better than they would bigger businesses.
Because, you know, if, say, your mom and pop shop, like, are getting, like, this extra income every month, right, they're going to have a much better time.
And with their operations, which I think is awesome.
Thank you.
I'll take my hand now.
Representative Somsich is recognized for a question.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Mr.
Wang, for testifying.
In light of the fact that you have Chinese origin here, as we all know, China is currently the number one emitter of greenhouse gas emissions in the world.
Could you tell me something about what China is doing currently about greenhouse gas emissions?
So I haven't followed up too much recently, but I do know that well China actually has some pilot carbon pricing programs first time first time I've seen you know for a couple months ago when I checked and also I'm sure I'm sure that there are mechanisms we can do to actually make them engage more in such policies.
Okay, thank you.
That question was really not relevant to the subject of this bill.
Are there any further questions at this point in time?
Seeing none, we'll move on to our next speaker, who is Mr.
Walter Payne, a member of the public who is representing himself.
Mr.
Payne, you are now allowed to speak.
And please keep your remarks brief and to the point about why we need a study committee on this subject.
Thank you.
Dear House STE Committee, I support HB 394 because climate change will make life in New Hampshire and the rest of the world less wonderful for our children and grandchildren than it was for us.
Pricing carbon is the most efficient way to prevent that and knowledge of the likely effects of pricing carbon on New Hampshire can help all of us better plan for the future.
A study commissioned by the New England Power Generating Association last year found, in agreement with virtually all economists, that carbon pricing could be the vital tool for reaching the member state's target of reducing carbon emissions to 80 percent by the year 2050 at the lowest possible cost.
It's estimated that an efficient carbon pricing system would save New Hampshire ratepayers somewhere between $10 and $30 million over 10 years when compared with non-market systems to reduce emissions, such as New Hampshire's renewable portfolio standard.
In household terms, total annual energy costs in 2035 would be lower with a carbon fee than without, partially because it would incentivize the switch to more efficient electric vehicles and heat pumps for home heating.
Performing a wider ranging study under HB 394 on the impact of various forms of carbon pricing specifically on New Hampshire would help our elected representatives push for the policies best for our state, and perhaps more important, allow our residents, businesses, and state local governments to efficiently plan for the future by including a carbon price in their calculations when making energy-intensive investments.
Whether a family replacing a failing furnace, a manufacturer building a new factory, or a utility adding generating capacity, they all benefit from more accurate information about future energy costs.
It should be noted that while New Hampshire has no fossil fuel industry, it does have lots of clever engineering firms that will find innovative ways to produce renewable energy.
There are a lot of those already with carbon pricing creating greater incentives to switch to renewables.
There will be more of them.
Thank you for consideration and I appreciate you setting this mechanism up for the public to comment on bills.
Thank you.
Mr.
Payne.
Any questions for Mr.
Payne from members of the committee?
Seeing none, I thank you, Mr.
Payne, for your testimony.
You're welcome.
And remarkably so so it appears that we only have one more speaker left on this bill so i would call if i can find him on the list And I don't see John Gage's name on the list of attendees.
I would call on John Gage to speak.
However, I don't see his name on the list of attendees, so I can't click the button that allows him to speak.
So I guess we'll have to forego his testimony.
I know he submitted extensive written testimony on this bill, and I urge all the members of the committee to read that testimony.
I know he submitted extensive written testimony on this bill and I urge all the members of the committee to read that testimony.
Representative Oxenham, did you have a question?
Yes, I'm concerned because two of the presentations that I knew of, testimony was submitted.
I spoke with the individuals last evening and they certainly intended to be here.
Is there, do we have any understanding of why we're not seeing them on the Zoom?
Well, the list that I have of speakers was generated approximately one half hour before the start of our session.
So nobody had signed up to speak as of roughly 930 this morning beyond the people who we've already called on.
Is that your question?
Are you asking if there are other people who signed up to speak?
In part, I took notes when I went through as to how many people had sent in testimony through the STE system through the general court website.
And I anticipated hearing from two more speakers.
Excuse me for interrupting.
Excuse me.
I haven't recognized you yet.
A lot of people send in written testimony but then do not sign up to speak.
I don't know the reason to that but it happens quite frequently.
So I have no idea what the reason might be.
I do see a hand raise.
Suzanne Butcher has her hand raised and I will allow her to speak.
So Suzanne Butcher, go ahead.
You'll have two minutes to speak and to address any points that haven't already been raised.
There.
Can you hear me now?
Yes.
Okay, good.
Yeah, I wonder.
I know John Gage was planning on being here and probably others.
I'm Suzanne Butcher from Keene, and I'll be brief.
I really urge you to support HB 394 to study the impacts of carbon pricing on the people of New Hampshire.
Our country and the world are going to transition to a low carbon economy sooner or later.
If we act sooner and smarter, we'll avoid a lot of costs, huge costs.
3,500 economists, including George Shultz and Jim Baker and Janet Yellen, said in the Wall Street Journal that carbon pricing would be, quote, the most cost-effective lever to reduce carbon emissions at the scale and speed that's necessary.
Carbon fee and dividend, also known as carbon cashback, would put a price on carbon at the source, not at every gas station, at the mine, the refinery, or the port.
So that's much simpler administratively.
And it would distribute the money not to the government, but to citizens directly and equally.
It would put money in people's pockets to spend as they choose.
The vast majority of people, especially those with lower incomes, would come out ahead, receiving more in carbon cashback than they would spend in increased energy prices.
So carbon cashback is market-based.
It doesn't rely on regulations and subsidies.
It's revenue neutral.
Revenue neutral.
And it doesn't grow government.
It would protect our future by reducing carbon emissions quickly and steadily.
It will provide predictability to our businesses and incentivize energy efficiency and clean energy production in New Hampshire.
Now we buy fossil fuels from out of state.
New Hampshire should plan for and prepare for a low-carbon future and identify and support the best ways to get there.
Carbon cashback has broad support when people understand it across the political spectrum and across the nation.
When you hear some people or politicians say they fee on carbon won't fly, they're not focusing on the cashback provisions that make it work and make it broadly popular.
Because national carbon pricing is likely, our state should pull the stakeholders together and evaluate what the change will mean for New Hampshire and make recommendations on how best to respond to it.
I hope you'll support HB 394 and I'm happy to answer any questions.
Thank you very much.
We do have a couple of questions.
First up is Representative Crescent.
Thank you, Chair.
This is actually more of a point of order related to the previous discussion about attendees that were expected but aren't showing up.
At the beginning of the session, the information that you read said that we should be pausing the committee and adjourning later.
If members of the public can't get in, how would we determine that?
Thank you for that question.
We would determine that by them calling the telephone number that I read in the opening statement, which is 271-3600, and discussing their issue with the person who answers the phone, that person would then communicate with us and let us know if there was a problem on our end.
There is.
If there's a problem on our end, we would suspend this public hearing and reconvene later.
If the problem is with the person with the other end, then the hearing would continue.
Mr.
Chair, if I may interject out of turn here, I just received a phone call from John Gage.
He says that on his screen, he appears in the attendee list.
He.
out of turn here.
I just received a phone call from John Gage.
He says that on his screen he appears in the attendee list.
He is trying to get into the meeting.
He was scheduled to speak.
Could you repeat that phone number one more time?
The phone number is 271-3600.
I still do not see John Gage on that.
My understanding is he appears as CCL New Hampshire rather than John Gage.
I don't see that either.
That is there.
Yeah, so he's in there.
I do see a CCL NHRI.
It does have its hand raised, but I wasn't prepared to allow an organization that I wasn't familiar with to to talk so i will i will allow ccl-nh-ri to speak provided that um they can identify themselves as someone on the speaking list such as john gage who is listed on the speaking list as a member of the public representing himself.
Okay, who are allowed to speak?
Hello, Representative Vose.
Thank you so much for connecting me.
I have three different Zoom accounts, and somehow my computer was still logged in as one that i use as the state coordinator of citizens climate lobby a group that i volunteer with i'm sorry that i appeared as that i didn't attend it i actually tried to log out and log back in as myself but apparently that didn't change on your side so i am here representing myself as a Mr.
Gage, you are permitted to speak for two minutes.
Please make any new points that we haven't heard about why we need a study committee to study this issue.
Okay.
Do I have the ability to share a screen or would you just prefer me to speak.
Just prefer you to speak.
As was mentioned, economists recommend carbon pricing because it's the least cost method to reduce emissions.
And they recommend a full rebate of all of the money collected from fossil fuel producers back to households on a monthly basis and even shares as the most equitable way to manage the money that's collected and protect household purchasing power.
What we haven't spoken about in this meeting yet is prices and what's going on in the rest of the world.
A lot of climate economists have converged on a price of $100 per ton of CO2 by 2030 as the necessary price around the world in order to meet the Paris target commitments that every country in the world had signed up to four years ago and the recommitting, the U.S.
is recommitting to, I believe, this month, along with every other country.
So $100 per ton of CO2 would shock our economy if we did it right away.
They say we should do it incrementally.
We could start now and raise it by $10 a year and get to the necessary limit.
So there are 46 other countries in the world already pricing carbon.
China was mentioned before.
They have several tests with carbon pricing going on, but later this year, they plan on introducing national carbon pricing for several of their sectors.
Once they come into carbon pricing, there will be more than 20% of fossil fuels around the world under some form of carbon price.
Very few of them are close to the $100 a ton.
However, with border carbon adjustments, the EU and Canada will soon begin applying their carbon price on our exports into their borders.
This is going to, instead of us charging for our pollution and rebating the money back to households, our major trading partners will be collecting the money for our carbon pollution and using it in their economy.
Of course, this is going to strong arm the U.S.
into matching their carbon price.
Canada uses carbon fee and dividend.
They will reach $130 per ton U.S.
by 2030.
The EU is committed to put border carbon adjustments in place by 2023, which is going to, and working with Canada, start charging us their carbon price.
And that will also let them increase their carbon price, which is $27 a ton right now.
So we're doing lots of things in our state that aren't very efficient.
Even Reggie only puts $5 per ton price on carbon emissions for 20% of our state's fossil fuel use.
We need a comprehensive solution, and that's carbon pricing at the source where it comes out of the ground, and we need it to be able to spread around the world because we can't do this alone, and the U.S.
is only responsible for 13% of global emissions.
Okay, Mr.
Kahn, I appreciate your testimony.
Before I open it up to other folks for questions, I have a question myself.
A recently released study by Jessica Green, an associate professor of political science at the University of Toronto, undertook one of the first comprehensive studies of carbon taxes and their existing carbon taxes and their effectiveness around the country.
And she discovered that of all the carbon tax schemes that are in existence today, they have produced very minimal results.
Average annual reductions ranging from zero to 1.5% per annum, whereas the IPCC states that emissions must fall below 45% by 2030 in order to be effective.
So the carbon pricing schemes that are in existence today don't seem to be working very well.
Are you confident that the carbon pricing scheme that you've discussed will actually work?
Yes, I am, because it all comes down to the price.
And the average carbon price around the world is about $4 per ton.
It's not a strong price signal to change behavior.
Why aren't countries using a strong enough price?
Well, the U.S., with the biggest economy, really is the powerhouse here.
Other countries can put some price on carbon, but at a certain point, they have to worry about leakage.
And that is by raising the cost of their energy, they can leak jobs and businesses to other countries.
And when they import goods produced in those countries, they're leaking carbon because of what they're buying that's produced elsewhere that doesn't have a price.
So this is where the dividend really becomes the magic.
Economists have converged.
As someone else mentioned, there was an economist statement where nearly every leading U.S.
economist says, agrees, we should put a steadily increasing price on carbon and rebate all the money back to households.
This protects purchasing power, but it also makes it politically viable.
The carbon cashback thing that we did in this state in 2020 showed voters, 70% of towns are in favor of carbon pricing if all the money is returned.
They asked our state and federal legislators to implement carbon fee and dividend by voting for it.
And some towns voted 97% in favor of that.
That was Holderness and Plymouth.
Others that missed it just missed it by a couple votes.
There's a strong urge among the public to address climate change, and economists say cash back carbon pricing is the most cost effective and equitable way to do it.
Canada is a great example of that this does work.
Right now they've only got a price of $30 per ton, which isn't enough to move mountains, but they just increased their ambition.
Instead of stopping at $50 per ton, they're going to go up to $130 a ton because the cashback approach is working for them.
So yeah, right now we haven't seen much because the average price is $4 a ton, but there's no other policy that comes close to the power of carbon pricing.
But we have to use it correctly.
You can't look at improperly administered policy and say, see, it doesn't work.
We have to use it in the proper way.
And it will work.
The economists are almost unanimous in their support for this.
We have to listen to the experts because none of us are.
Climate scientists say we have an identified threat with high certainty, and economists say this is the most cost-effective and equitable solution.
But the question here is not whether it's going to happen.
It is going to happen.
The trend around around the world is to price carbon.
The question is what should our state do about it?
And you talk a lot about how we can become more energy efficient and what's the best way to do that and subsidize clean energy in this committee.
Carbon pricing will make states more competitive that have lower carbon footprints per their economic strength.
And so by becoming more energy efficient and by switching off of fossil fuels, we can become more competitive and we can either wait until everybody else has done it or we can get ahead of the game.
Okay.
Yeah.
Representative Pimentel, do you have a question for Mr.
Gage?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
First of all, I want to apologize for interrupting earlier.
I was merely trying to inform you that Mr.
Gage was in the participant list under CCLNH.
But I do apologize for interrupting.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Mr.
Gage, could you explain to me what, I mean, I assume a lot of people think that why don't we just wait for the federal level to go ahead and implement some kind of a carbon cash back?
But I understand most of the other New England states are now in the process of implementing something like this.
And what's going to happen if other states in New England do it and we don't?
Well, that's a good question.
So there's lots of ways to reduce your state's carbon footprint.
Carbon pricing is the most cost-effective way to do it.
You know, Massachusetts has lots of programs.
Some of them are quite expensive, but they are reducing their carbon footprint.
What that means when there's a national price and a global price on carbon emissions is Massachusetts will become naturally more competitive than we are because their whole economy produces less carbon.
They will be paying less for their carbon emissions because they will have less.
So the question is, how do we want to deal with this?
And we can just wait until the federal price happens to us.
And if we have a relatively high carbon footprint, our businesses and our towns are gonna be paying higher prices due to that fee.
Now the citizens will be getting that money back.
But, you know, if we're much higher than other states and everybody across the country is getting the same money back, our higher prices are going to be hurting us and other states will be more competitive.
So, you know, really the question is, how can you use the insights that the world will have a price of $100 per ton on carbon by 2030 to your advantage?
You know, I believe that you want to become more energy efficient and you want to begin the transition of your costly energy infrastructure that stays in place for decades, transitioning it to clean energy solutions now so that you don't, you know, if you're a homeowner and you get a report from our state that says, you know, we know it's cheaper to buy an oil furnace right now.
However, we believe that it's a better choice to make a heat pump decision because this will be heating your home for 20 30 years, and it might be cheaper for the next five years, but then it's going to be more expensive for the next 25 years if you make that choice.
You know, people just don't see this coming, and they're looking for our state leaders to kind of advise them, how can we spend the least amount on energy what are the good decisions for us to make sticking our heads in the thank you for that answer mr gage next up is representative mcgee thank you mr chairman and thank you mr gage for your testimony um i also would like to thank you for the context that you've brought to the hearing because we're not talking today about whether we should pass climate change legislation.
We're talking about whether we should study the fact that we may not have all the answers as to how to interpret this for the state and for its energy economy.
And I think that's what, for me, raises the question of delaying, since we're retaining bills that are committees and commissions as a matter of course this term, what the delay would do.
And so my question is around, I'll just say one other thing too.
Earlier it was mentioned that New Hampshire has lowered its carbon emissions in recent years, and that's true in the electric generation sector.
We have brought our emissions down over recent years.
We just had a report from New Hampshire DES saying that that will plateau this year, so we're not actually going to continue going down.
The major sector that we haven't addressed is transmission.
And I just saw an article saying that General Motors has announced that it will no longer be making combustible vehicles.
It will be moving to all electrics by 2035.
So it just speaks to what is moving on around us that we actually have to figure out what are the right moves for New Hampshire.
So could you just say something about the timing of all of this?
Because even if we have a study commission, we really won't have any action on that for another year or two years.
Yes.
Well, you know, I believe for our state's benefit, had the state gone ahead with carbon fee and dividend at the state level last year, we would be in a really much better position to see this.
The fee starts low and increases gradually, but it sends a strong signal about what the future looks like.
And one of the things that's important is businesses and others who make energy decisions, they don't care as much about the short-term fluctuations as the long-term prospects.
And so we are simply missing opportunity by waiting.
Had we figured out how to be really energy efficient by now, you know, this stuff is more expensive the less time you have to do it.
So if we start earlier, then all the homes that need new furnaces and people that are buying cars would be making different choices if they had full information, if they had a complete information of what's going on in the market and could see a carbon price of $100 per ton in 10 years.
So if we delay a year or two, this is just missing opportunity.
We're increasing our costs.
We're going to be spending more to make conversions.
We're going to have more stranded costs as the equipment that we decide to buy now because of current market pricing becomes obsolete when there is a carbon price.
I just feel like the science and the economics is so clear and the trends of carbon pricing around the world are so clear.
And the IPCC statement that carbon pricing is a necessary factor of getting emissions down globally as needed to meet the targets that every country in the world has agreed we need to do.
Okay, thank you, Mr.
Gage.
Next up is Representative John Mann.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Gage.
I was really impressed with your comment about we don't want to be last in New England about understanding the effects of the climate tax.
We have an analogous situation in electric costs.
We've been outstripped by Massachusetts, Maine, and Vermont in energy efficiency work.
And the regional grid assigns costs of transmission according to how much electricity you use.
And I found that our transmission since 2016 to 2020, my first 650 kilowatt hour customer, his electric bill, the transmission part only has gone up $6 a month.
And that's just an example of what we can get stuck with if we wanna be last in the queue.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you, Representative Mann.
I didn't really hear a question there, so...
Oh, that's, yeah, would you believe?
Next up is Representative Parshall.
Don't forget to unmute, Representative.
My best, sir.
Thank you.
So even setting aside the threats of inaction, the benefits of moving forward with a study group that seems imperative to me, only encouraging our economic stimulus.
And my question is, is there a way to calculate the lost costs for every day that we delay enacting this kind of legislation?
Well, the external costs of using fossil fuels, there's a new branch of science called attribution science.
They're calculating how much damage the impacts of global warming are having on the U.S.
It used to be counted in the tens of billions of dollars a couple decades ago.
Last year, it was about $200 billion.
So the costs of inaction at the federal level are rapidly increasing.
And there are tipping points that are just simply irrecoverable problems, species lost, people dying.
You can melt enough ice in the polar regions to absorb more of the sun's energy instead of reflecting it back to space that then you get additional positive feedback warming.
And then you have to address that problem in addition to the problems caused by our pollution.
So every year is getting more expensive.
You know, but the...
the problems caused by our pollution.
So every year is getting more expensive.
But New Hampshire can't solve climate change.
What we could do is show the country and the world that we can pick a sensible, practical, bipartisan approach to addressing the pollution.
The state could recommend to Congress that we would like them to do carbon fee and dividend, but even for our own competitiveness, we should prepare for carbon pricing.
We should use this bill to get all the stakeholders together and make it out apparent that energy efficiency is helpful now, but when carbon pricing kicks in and energy becomes more expensive temporarily, but it will be for a decade or two, that energy efficiency is going to pay back even more.
Okay, thank you, Mr.
Gage.
I appreciate your comments, your extensive comments.
I know you have submitted extensive written testimony.
I urge every member of the committee to read that testimony.
Unfortunately, we're going to have to move on.
And the reason is simple.
We started another public hearing on HB 410 at 11 o'clock and then recessed it.
We now have 22 minutes to complete the public hearing on that bill and we have at least three people who would like to speak.
So we're going to have to move on.
Mr.
Chair, couldn't we take some time out of our lunch break rather than curtail the proper deliberation on the next bill?
I hardly think that it's fair to deprive members of a break in the middle of the day.
So just a shorter break.
Could we have a show of hands as to whether people would prefer to?
We have no need to continue to debate this bill since at best it will be retained and we'll have plenty of time to talk about it later.
But it's a discourtesy to the people who are waiting to testify on HB 410 to delay discussion of that bill any longer.
Excuse me, Mr.
Chair, I think you misunderstood me.
I'm trying to make sure 410 gets its full hour of a hearing by curtailing our lunch period.
I certainly agree that we should suspend any more consideration of my bill.
Okay.
It's possible that we can go longer than the 12 o'clock hour for this bill.
Depends on public testimony and the questions go so with that we will uh right before closing the hearing on hb 394 i'll report that 117 people signed up to support this bill one signed up to oppose it and with that we close the hearing on HB 394 and resume the hearing on hb 410 and i call on the prime sponsor of the bill hb 410 to give us a brief introduction to the bill thank you mr chairman i'm representative burna prime sponsor we filed this bill a year ago um as a result of the deregulation of the utilities selling off their generation.
The companies that purchased them, we worked on a bill two sessions ago, I should back up quick.
It was a possible 700 that took about a year and a half, two years to complete, with a lot of help from both sides.
And we came up with a near perfect bill.
The problem that was missing was the utilities not reporting the inventory or what they have at their plans or their generation site.
So none of the generation.
And the new owners of the plans have not filed.
These plates have all been sold since 2017 2017 so there's been a lot of lost revenue it was requested by about 15 towns i have someone who's going to speak on that briefly so myself and representative of brahmi worked on this bill last winter extensively we spent a month working meeting with utilities and property owners and we found the problem and we found the best way going forward so we don't step on anything that was done in the hard work when 700 was worked on that we put a study committee together and i'll leave it at that okay thank you representative merner are there any questions for representative thomas thank you, Representative Murner.
Are there any questions for Representative Murner?
Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, for taking my question.
Thank you for taking my question.
I know you just mentioned the reason why, but could you go into just a briefly more of the reasons why you think we need to have a study committee versus what all of you said you did over the summer, why did you come up with an actionable bill well we felt we needed a little more work excuse me excuse me mr chairman we cannot hear what representative thomas just said would you please repeat your question representative thomas i'm wondering i'm wondering i want to second that it's very difficult i don't know what the use of the microphone is or what, but it's it's very difficult to understand what's being said on that audio.
I have a mic to my left and I have a mic in front of me, so I'll try again.
Representative Murder, I know that you explained briefly why you thought we needed a study committee, but with all the work that you did over the summer, working with Representative Abrami, could you go into just a little more detail as to why you still think we need a study committee versus coming up with an actionable bill?
We didn't actually work over the summer.
It worked.
Then we brought it back to the committee as a study bill going forward last year, and it died in the Senate cobit um we did feel that you know we needed more work on it obviously uh representative obrami worked really hard on on the equalization bills that utility utilization which mike i think it was 2017 in one month we marked down i think we had 13 hours of testimony on that retained bill.
So we didn't want to undo all the hard work that we all put into that bill at the time.
I attended all those meetings and we didn't want to step on any toes and make sure everything worked.
So that was the trevice of going forward with the Senate bill.
Okay, thank you.
That's good.
Representative Somsich, you have a question?
Thank you.
That's good.
Representative Somsich, you have a question?
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Mr.
Representative Murner.
Is it your testimony today or your intention that you'd like us to move ahead with an ITL on this study, even with the sword of Damocles hanging over it to retain it?
I think I got what you said.
I mean, I think we're looking at retaining it because it is a study committee bill to retain it for right now.
That's what I'm looking for.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Any other questions for Representative Murdur?
Seeing none, I will call on the next speaker, who is George San Susi, a member of the public who is representing approximately 80 communities within New Hampshire as their utility appraiser.
So, Mr.
Sansouci, you are permitted to talk.
Go ahead, Mr.
Sandsusi.
San Suzy?
The only San Suzy I have in my attendee list is actually listed as Austin San Suzy.
I assume George San Suzy is using that account.
Is that correct?
And if so, go ahead, you're ready to speak.
Okay, Mr.
Sansusi appears to have stepped away.
So we'll move to our next speaker, who is Shirelle Lucas, also a member of the public, but also representing 80 communities within the state as their utility appraiser.
Looking at the list of attendees, I don't see a Sherelle Lucas listed.
Mr.
Chairman?
Yes.
Mr.
Chairman, I'm George Sansouci, to speak, and Sherelle Lucas set it up.
She is one of my employees.
We're all one person.
I see.
Okay.
Well, I recognized you to speak a moment ago.
You do have the floor.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
House Bill 400 has been introduced to you to solve a bipartisan problem.
I provided a cover letter and two pages of bullet points that outline the problem that needs to be rectified.
This bill was introduced last year and got COVID-ed to death.
so it has been reintroduced this year because this problem is very real and has not gone away.
When the legislature enacted House Bill 700, they corrected half of this reporting problem.
The problem is very simple.
The regulated and unregulated public utilities and generation companies, including hydroelectric companies, I really like that.
The regulated and unregulated public utilities and generation companies, including hydroelectric companies, are refusing and have refused to report any information to the towns and cities for the purpose of the towns and cities valuing the property for their taxes.
The argument has been that they are not legally responsible or required to report to the towns and cities, so they don't.
What is important to note is that it affects a tremendous number of communities in the state, and we have provided you with the list of communities and the number of utilities that have a history of non-reporting.
Some of the, this is not a public service issue because they do report Eversource, but that doesn't mean if they were sold that they would continue to report.
When Granite State Electric was sold by New England Power Company, by New England Electric Systems to National Grid, they stopped reporting any further information to the towns and cities for a period of 10 to 12 years until House Bill 700 was enacted.
The purpose of this bill is to require the utilities to report the relatively simple but necessary levels of information to the towns and cities on an annual basis so the towns and cities can accurately prepare their assessment valuations.
The utilities are very large taxpayers, as you would know, because of the extent of their infrastructure.
New England Power Company and National Grid are the largest problem children in the state.
New England Power Company owns a number of transmission lines that they do not report that drain the hydroelectric plants on the Connecticut River.
They own half of the Merrimack Valley transmission system that was just finished, and they're not reporting to Pelham and Hudson as an example.
They also are the lead participant that manages the Hydro-Quebec Phase 1 and Phase 2 lines.
These are the big DC lines from Canada that go from Littleton, New Hampshire, all the way through Hudson and into Massachusetts to provide Hydro-Quebec electricity to New England.
They have not reported those lines in a very long time.
When they do appeal, it is only through the courts that we get reporting.
Hydro-Quebec phase one is from Littleton to Monroe, and it has the major substation that's not reported in Monroe.
That was the first phase that was built, and phase two was Monroe, New Hampshire, to Hudson Town Line.
That line is actually bigger than Northern Pass that was being promoted and is not reported.
When public service sold its power plants to Central River, Central River bought the hydroelectric plants.
There are eight of them in the state.
They have never reported since the hydroelectric plants.
That is very important because in hydroelectric plants, you do need at least energy and operating income and expenses with which to consider value under the uniform standards of appraisal practice and the state of New Hampshire's appraisal standard boards and the DRA.
They They also, when they sold the fossil plants, Schiller, Newington, Bow, and the Peking Turbans in Northumberland and White Lake in Tamworth, that company has also not reported.
We do have spotty sometimes and sometimes on, sometimes off reporting of the large diameter gas transmission lines by Tennessee Gas, by Maritimes and Northeast coming down from Maine, and by Portland Natural Gas Transmission.
By and large, though, we do get some reporting from those utilities, but our goal is to codify that so everybody knows what it is that is expected.
So that is the purpose of this bill.
I would strongly urge that you look at the list of companies and the types of companies.
They are your major taxpayers in the state Thank you.
They are your major taxpayers in the state, in your communities, your constituent communities.
And this is something that we have needed now for about 10 to 15 years.
And I would ask your consideration in representing approximately 60 to 70 of these communities on your behalf.
With that, I'll answer any questions if you have any.
Thank you, Mr.
Sands.
Before I open it up to questions, can I ask you if anyone else from your office be testified?
What say?
Before I open it up to questions, can I ask you if anyone else from your office will be testifying?
No, I'm doing the testimony for everybody.
Okay, great.
And I recognize Representative Thomas for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Schieder.
Sansouci, for taking my question.
I really have just a very neutral question.
I call this bill 700 and I recall the extensive economy took.
I think it was a two year period where they had study committees that went over that that resulted in in what we have now.
Can you tell me?
I'm sure you were part of that at one time.
Can you tell me with all the extensive committee that work they did back then that was well over a year long?
Why wasn't this issue addressed at that time?
Or if it was, what was the result of not covering it because you're saying it didn't cover but half of what was needed.
So can you elaborate on that?
Yes, I can.
And that's an excellent question.
The House Bill 700 was to, the purpose of House Bill 700 was to address the distribution utilities that are regulated by the New Hampshire Public Utilities Commission.
They are the retail distribution utilities.
These utilities were never included in that debate on how to value the New Hampshire regulated communities.
These are all companies and property which is regulated at the federal level by the Federal Energy Regulatory Commission and not the state level.
The only level of regulation at the state level is the siting of these facilities, but their rates and their actions and their activity is regulated at the federal level.
And the decision that the legislature legislators made was the complexities of federal legislation, federal regulation was so different than the complexities of local regulation for House Bill 700, that they did not want to mix the two because it would have essentially just would not have worked because it was just two completely different situations.
That is the reason why they were taken out of the consideration for House Bill 700 and cast aside for a later legislation, which was introduced last year.
And that's what this legislation is, to deal with them differently, because they are different in how they report and what they report, and would have been contradictory in some instances to House Bill 700.
So that's the reason, sir.
Very good.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
My pleasure.
Okay.
Next question, Representative Oxenham.
Yes.
I'm also puzzled why we're being asked to study this again.
It seems like there's a clear solution available.
Is it possible for an amendment to be brought that takes us away from being a study committee, which is then going to be retained?
I understand this bill needs to go to a second committee for consideration.
Is there a way forward that we can get to a solution without just making this thing hang fire for endless periods.
Question for the chair, actually.
That's not to me.
Mr.
Chair, I'm sorry.
I didn't say at the outset that my question was to you rather than to the questioner, the speaker of the moment.
It's about this being a study committee, whether or not we could, it seems like there's a solution available here that could be put into an amendment and we wouldn't have to have yet another study committee retained, more delay.
I heard your question.
Thank you for it.
I prefer the answer to Representative Murner.
Yes, in discussion, I discussed this when I went to file a bill.
I discussed it with Representative Browning and the parties and Mr.
Sandsusi.
And we felt everything that had gone on the last three years which was just explained to representative thomas that we go forward with a study committee right now okay uh we have any additional questions seeing none and seeing that we have no further speakers signed up to speak on this uh on this issue on this question i guess uh we can bring this public hearing to a close as well and remarkably we've done so on time.
The blue sheet says that nine people signed up to support this bill, zero people signed up to oppose it.
And with that, notable people who signed up to support it were Kenneth Mertz, who's a spokesman in New Hamman in New Hampshire, Senator Aaron Hattie, Timothy Egan, and Joseph De Palma.
Those were the elected officials who signed up to support this bill.
So with that, I'll close the public hearing on HB 410.
And we will, between 12 and 1 o'clock, take a lunch break.
And we will return at 1 o'clock to hear HB 543.
Thank you this morning.
It was very productive.
And I thank you all.
We'll see you at one o'clock She wants a very deep guest.
Can you hear us?
You?
Well, I'm enjoying you, but I'm not sure I'm going to speak with the school.
E a Obrigado.
Thank you.
If you're ready to begin, the room just needs to be unmuted.
From the station up front.
We are unmuted.
Okay, we are unmuted.
Is that correct?
Yep, you are good to go.
Okay, thank you.
All right, everyone.
Hope you had a good lunch.
Welcome back to the afternoon session for the Science, Technology, and Energy Committee.
We have four bills to deal with this afternoon, and the very first one is House Bill 543.
So I will open the public hearing on House Bill 543.
that seeks to establish a commission to study nuclear power and nuclear reactor technology in New Hampshire.
And the prime sponsor of said bill is Representative Keith Ammon.
And, Representative Ammon, you are allowed to speak and the floor is yours.
Great.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And I'm going to assume that you can hear me.
Yes.
We hear you.
That's every Zoom call has to start with that.
Thank you for allowing me to introduce House Bill 543.
The bill seeks to establish a commission to study nuclear power and nuclear reactor technology in New Hampshire, and I thank the committee members for their time.
Some of you may know I served on science, technology, and energy in 2017 to 18, so I got to be familiar with many of the issues that come before the committee.
During that time, we took a field trip to the sea coast, or to the nuclear power plant on the sea coast.
And that was very enlightening.
One thing that caught my eye was what's called the second pad site, which is now a dilapidated concrete structure.
So it's a location where a nuclear power plant could have been built, was not built.
As you may be aware, nuclear technology, and I'm not an expert, but I am an enthusiast, has been advancing the last few decades.
And there's something called Generation 4 nuclear technology, which purports to be safer, more compact, and something that could be the future of energy production, could contribute to energy production.
So the Senate has telegraphed that they're going to be putting the kibosh on study bills this year because of the expedited legislative process due to the pandemic.
So I'm asking the committee if you would please retain this bill for 2022.
I spoke with ranking member Somsich about the bill, and there may be some improvements to make it bipartisan, to make it more bipartisan.
One of them is the structure of the committee.
Representative Somsich pointed out that it does favor Republicans and I'm open to making the selection a little more bipartisan.
And then also the duties of the commission are quite extensive in the bill.
I think they could probably be narrowed down.
Section B is probably the most interesting.
Section 3B, it talks about the Generation for International Forum, which was established in 2001.
And they have been, it's an international group.
They have been studying different Generation 4 designs.
A lot of them have to do with higher temperatures.
So they use things like molten salt or molten lead to get higher temperatures to be able to generate more electricity and they've they've narrowed things down to uh narrowed the designs down to the six listed in the bill but that's a good resource if and when this study commission goes forward um there's a chinese proverb it says the best time to plant a tree was 20 years ago.
The second best time is now.
You've probably heard that before.
And so this bill is forward-looking.
If we're going to be serious about eliminating carbon from our economy, nuclear power, I believe, should be part of the discussion.
And the Generation 4 International Forum says that some of these designs may be commercially deployed within the next 10 years.
So I think beginning next year, 2022, if we start getting serious about investigating this technology and making New Hampshire a place where that's welcoming to this new technology.
We can transition away from energy sources that produce carbon.
So with that, I'd like to repeat that I'd like the committee to retain this bill, and I'm happy to answer any questions.
Thank you, Representative.
The chair recognizes Representative Harrington for a question.
Yeah, thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you for taking my question, Representative.
I'm looking at this, and I'm just trying to figure out what it is this commission hopes to accomplish.
Given that nuclear power is 100% regulated by the NRC through the federal government, the state has very little to do with licensing or anything somewhat to do with developing emergency planning.
And there is all sorts of stuff going along across the world on nuclear power.
There's SMRs, which are small modular reactors.
You mentioned molten salt, high temperature.
There's a bunch of new potential technologies out there.
But I'm just not sure what is this commission going to accomplish?
Because you're still talking probably billions of dollars.
And I'm just not sure how this is going to produce anything that's going to make somebody more interested in building nuclear power plants in New Hampshire.
Well, you're absolutely correct.
It's a lot to do with federal regulations where new plants are sited.
One of the duties of the commission would be to look for partnerships with federal agencies, including the U.S.
Nuclear Reaction Commission.
It's a long shot, but nobody's talking about it.
So how do we make it, and I see people laughing in the background there.
How do we make this possible?
Because, you know, it should be part of our future to have nuclear power, electricity generated by nuclear power.
It has a lot of promises.
Thank you for that question and response.
Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
I agree that some work could be done on the contents of this bill but are you suggesting that in the very short future that new types of nuclear power reactors which produce zero emissions directly versus over a slow period of time is possible and that this commission would be the studying ways for both public relations and technology wise that it could be done here in New Hampshire.
Is that the intent of this commission?
Yeah, that's correct.
I believe this would be the first step in starting a longer conversation.
And that conversation, to my knowledge, isn't happening right now.
So it is a forward-looking bill and to attract attention and expertise to our state with a very promising way to produce electricity.
Does that answer your question?
Follow up.
Thank you.
Yes, and I would agree that if this were to be retained, you would be willing to work on putting some different words in here and, you know, tidying it up.
So it, you know, based on our conversation today and what work may happen before this gets snacked upon next year, correct?
Absolutely.
I'm totally willing to pitch in and, you know, do the heavy lifting on any modifications that the committee requests.
Thank you.
Representative Bernardi is recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
Is it your understanding that the generation four reactors could be suitably cited, say, at the second pad at the Seabird Station or similar environs, do they still require some degree of cooling water which this ocean provides?
It's my understanding there are different designs.
Some of them require water, which would be suitable to a site like the second pad site.
And there are other advanced designs that purport to require no cooling water.
So they could be sited, you know, in many different locations, including close to the source of consumption.
So that would cut down on transmission costs.
That's my understanding.
Thank you.
Representative Ploge is recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
I'm with 246 new types of nuclear energy, is there any actual commercial or community reactors processing now, like power?
Why?
I'm sorry, I missed the middle part of your question.
I'll speak into the mic.
Okay.
Are there any of these new generation four nuclear plants in operation worldwide?
It's my understanding that in China, they're moving ahead with this generation four technology.
They see it as very promising to their energy needs.
And I believe also in France, but I'd have to double check that.
The US Department of Energy has a program to accelerate nuclear, these new nuclear reactor types, partnering with private industry, and they're looking to make them commercially available, optimistically five years, but probably more like 10 years.
and you know know, these are big projects.
So I think it's wise for our state to start looking at, you know, being attractive to these new projects as they roll out.
Follow up.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking this one.
From what I've seen or read, this idea is efficiency of it when they come out with the numbers of cost to BTUs put out.
Are really planned, are in a planned community so waste heat can be used and things like that so with things like this be feasible for uh the pad number two where the community is not planned around this plant if it ever gets built thank you thank you yeah i can't speak to the The feasibility of pad number two, I mean, that would take an expert opinion, which I don't speak to the feasibility of pad number two.
I mean, that would take an expert opinion, which I don't have.
The structure that's there, I believe, would need to be torn down and rebuilt.
One thing that's really interesting about some of these new designs is that they can utilize spent nuclear fuel, and they have a much higher efficiency of utilizing fuel.
So one thing that comes to mind, and again, it would take some study to see if it's feasible, but there is a large storage of spent nuclear fuel at Seabrook.
So it's possible that in the not too distant future, instead of just having that fuel sit there and be a concern for the community, it may be possible to reuse it in one of these newer designs and actually not only get a benefit from it in the in the form of electricity, but also reduce the level of waste.
There's some talk like the half-life is in centuries instead of millennia after using spent fuel on these generation four plants.
One thing I'd also like to say is this is a bipartisan issue.
And I think you'll find that the younger generation is much more open to this idea in either party than maybe people that remember protests around nuclear power plants that happened in, say, the 70s with technology that was 50 years old.
So, you know, this gives some hope for the future to the young generation if we pursue this to some degree.
Okay, thank you, Representative.
Is is recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just want to thank the representative for bringing this bill to us.
The smiling that you saw is because I actually brought a nuclear bill in the last session.
And I'm married to a nuclear nuclear engineer so I know a whole bunch about the next generation stuff and I would actually offer to work with my colleague on this if it were allowed to move forward.
I think the broadness of the information in the bill currently especially under section B is based on sort of a laundry list of what's out there and available.
I think some of that has been narrowed in terms of people who actually know what's going on in that field.
And I've got somebody right here who's an expert I can talk to about it.
There are a couple of companies that are actually doing projects nearby.
At Point La Preux in New Brunswick, right across the border from Maine, they're putting in a molten salt reactor with a UK company called Moltex.
And there's another company, I think they're also doing molten salt reactors because they have higher capacity factors.
They use more of the energy, more efficient, as you were saying.
And that's terrestrial up in Canada, but there are others around the world.
So it's not really as far away as it used to be.
So I think it's a great idea for us to take a closer look at it, only because I think the problem in us getting off of fossil fuels has been a lot to do with the fact that we need base load generation.
So I'm just wondering, it sounds like you're saying this is a forward looking bill, which I appreciate.
And so, and I think Michael Harrington was saying the same thing.
If the bill could maybe be focused, would you be willing to focus the bill so that it had an objective of what we were trying to achieve with it which is maybe to um you know whether it's cleaning up generation or providing additional beneficial electrification so we can convert the trans you know transportation fleet like if it had some kind of a focus rather than just being sort of a uh an all-encompassing let's take a look at it.
I think it would maybe have better traction because to Representative Harrington's point, it's federally regulated.
So if we don't actually have a specific aim in what we're trying to do, we might not, you know, we might not get very far.
And it does appear that the federal government is going to be looking for ways to clean up the portfolio quickly.
So there might actually be some money to come to us to try and achieve something if we could improve the technology that we currently have at Seabrook in some way.
Yeah, I'm willing to focus the bill further.
I think the duties list is kind of a throw the spaghetti against the wall and see what sticks.
But yeah, we could certainly narrow that down.
I mean, there are some exciting, you know, non-electric applications.
I think the prospect of using nuclear to generate hydrogen as an energy storage technology, I think that's something that will come eventually.
And water needs with population is also going to require desalinization, which is another thing that these heavy capacity plants are good at.
Yeah, I mean, heat for industrial processes, that's a byproduct that could be useful, right?
So, yeah, I'm happy to work with you, Kat, if you want to narrow this down and tap into the expertise in your household.
Well, it sounds like we're going to have a lot of time to do it.
Yeah, I hope so.
Enjoy yourself.
I recognize Representative Somsich for a question.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Representative Ammon, for bringing this bill.
Just because I was mentioned previously about our conversations that I had with Representative Ammon, I just wanted to underscore what he said and confirm that I thought this was a very interesting bill.
And I too had said I would be willing to work on something like this.
After all, I have had experience in the nuclear energy industry and issues surrounding it.
However, as was mentioned, the scope of this bill is just so expansive that, you know, if I wanted to have a couple year project just as a hobby, I could spend lots of time on this.
I've gone to conferences on one specific area over the last 10 years.
So there's a lot to cover here.
So if it could be narrowed down, it would make a lot of sense.
But I do have one question as well.
And that is, don't you think that in fact, a carbon pricing bill, if it's passed, actually would benefit promoting nuclear energy?
But it, I mean, it depends on how it's engineered by, you know, the people at the top, right?
So, uh, I think the focus of this bill is more just to see what possibilities there are for our state and just focusing it on nuclear energy.
I'd have to get back to you on the carbon pricing, not knowing the details of it.
Well, follow up, Mr.
Chair.
Follow up.
Yeah.
Why I asked this specifically because I've read several articles about this recently in scientific magazines.
And there is a real opportunity for some nuclear operators to be able to get credit for not being greenhouse gas emitting.
And if they if that is priced out as part of their energy energy, obviously that would benefit them.
Okay, I don't disagree.
If you think that should be a duty in this bill, then maybe we could consider adding it.
Thank you.
As part of the equation.
Thank you, Representative Hammond.
I remind committee members that we're here to ask questions, not make comments.
Representative Jacqueline Callie-Pitts, don't forget to unmute.
My question is basically for the chair and I want to say first I want to apologize for being late.
I lose my link every time I close out.
So I don't know what happens.
Right after the 102 message from Kat, it was gone.
But I want to thank you also for saying that this is not to comment on the bill and solve what would be a normal committee, subcommittee work session, and people volunteering to work on things now, where I think a lot of people are interested, including myself.
I was there at the dawn of nuclear age.
But I would like to know if, and this is for the chair, are we going to be able to volunteer and work on subcommittees on some of these bills that are being retained in the future?
I think that question is directed to the chair.
Yes, to the chair, yes.
Absolutely.
We'll be putting together study committees on all these retained bills.
So everybody, in essence, will have a chance to work and listen in on these.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
That is our standard operating procedure.
Right.
I just wanted to reiterate.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
I see no more hands raised.
Oh, yes, I do.
I see one more hand raised.
Representative Emmettel is recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Emmant, this is very intriguing.
I like the idea of us being able to do something with all of that unspent fuel in Seabrook.
However, I'm wondering how much of a demand do we have in New Hampshire for more generated electricity, seeing as that we do already have Seabrook?
How much of a demand do we have?
Are you asking me to predict what the market needs for additional nuclear energy?
Is that what you're saying?
Specifically, the market is there for electricity.
Certainly, we could be a primary exporter of electricity.
But what I'm wondering about is, is that the market we want to get into?
Or do we have a market for that electricity here in New Hampshire?
Well, I think one interesting thing about this approach, and you kind of have to put your imagination forward into the future, is transmission costs are part of the equation for energy costs.
And these newer technologies allow smaller reactors, even micro reactors possibly, to be sited very close to where the energy is consumed.
So you understand that there's loss in the power transmission over long distances.
I think that partially answers your question.
you know, you understand that there's loss in the power transmission over long distances.
You know, energy costs are an issue in New Hampshire and in the region more broadly.
And if we're concerned about removing carbon from our economy, you know, from production, it seems to me nuclear is the clear, is one of the possible solutions.
Something to think about, right?
We talk about renewables, we talk about hydro and solar and wind.
All three of those energy sources are driven by the sun, which is a giant nuclear reactor.
So, you know, to think that nuclear power can't be part of the equation, I think is short-sighted.
And, you know, the market will decide how much need there is for it.
Thank you.
can't be part of the equation, I think is short-sighted.
And, you know, the market will decide how much need there is for it.
But at least, you know, New Hampshire is a state.
We should be investigating and putting some feelers out to see if we can attract interest and, you know, the skill set needed to be able to develop a project like this.
You know, and I think it has to start with a study commission.
I don't see any other way to do it.
You know, they're not my favorite type of bills, but because this subject matter is fairly complex, it requires expert input.
I think we would need a study commission to, you know, move the ball forward.
You need a follow-up representative.
I'm fine.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, representative Ammon.
Thank you, chair.
Thank you.
Thank you, representative Ammon for being here today.
And the chair now recognizes Representative Harrington for a question.
Yeah, I wasn't going to ask much as a question as a comment, because it seems to be some people get confused over the situation with Seabrook 2.
There is no Seabrook 2.
Everything's gone.
There's land there.
All the reactor parts and everything have been sold off.
The pressure, all the pressure vessel, everything's gone.
The one thing it does has is it does have a cooling capacity.
It's sufficient for two reactors because that's what it was designed for.
But I don't really see anybody building there.
As far as other technologies, someone had asked a question earlier about what was being done.
Probably the most advanced of the new technologies in the United States is what's referred to as SMRs or small modular reactors.
And there's a company that just had their initial design phase approved by the NRC and doing negotiations to actually build one of these out in, I think it's Idaho.
And the advantage of these is that they're built in factories and shipped in units that are, like they say, small modular.
So typically somewhere in the range of 50 to 80 megawatts.
And then you can just stack them up to get as much as you need.
So just a little bit.
Mr.
Chairman, I want to make Representative Harrington aware that we're asking questions here.
We're not debating nuclear technology.
That would be a different topic.
Thank you.
I appreciate the excitement.
I would remind all members that we're here to gather information and ask questions, statements, and comments when we have an executive session.
Mr.
Chair?
Yes, Mr.
Representative Bannon.
Yeah, so the modular aspect is very interesting because you could, in the near future, you could start a project very small with, you know, a single unit, as Representative Harrington was talking about.
And so, you know, the initial commitment could be much smaller than, say, building an entire second reactor, you know, similar to the first one at Seabrook.
It could literally be, you know, a shipping container size unit as your initial capital outlay.
And then, you know, you can stack those up over time as investment comes, you know, online.
So the modular aspect is something in the bill.
And I think that's kind of exciting.
Intriguing idea for sure.
So thank you, Representative Ammon.
I have no other questions lined up, and there are no other speakers on this bill.
Is there anyone in the attendee section who would like to raise their hand and speak on this bill seeing none i'm going to close the public hearing on house bill four 543.
and i thank representative and for being here to support the bill and introduce the bill before Before we close the hearing officially, I will point out that there were five people who signed up to support the bill, four who signed up to oppose it.
And there was one elected official who signed it and supported the bill that was representative .
So with that, we'll close the public hearing on house bill 543 and we will exit to executive session and i will recognize representative murder for a motion on House Bill 410.
Yes, House Bill 410.
I make a motion that we retain the bill.
The chair recognizes Representative Kloge.
I'd like to second that motion, Mr.
Chair.
So Representative Myrner has moved that we retain house bill 410 and representative floje has seconded that motion is there any discussion Seeing none, I ask the clerk, the acting clerk, to call the roll on the motion to retain House Bill 410.
543, isn't it?
I thank Representative Nott for running out and getting me more.
543.
No, no, 410.
410.
We're doing 410.
Oh, 410.
We're backing up.
Okay.
Motion moved and seconded to retain House Bill 410.
Representative Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Harrington.
Representative Nodda.
Yes.
Representative Myrna.
Representative Humala.
Yes.
Representative Fumala, yes.
Representative Resney, yes.
Representative Bernadette, yes.
Representative Kimbrough, yes.
Representative Ploje, yes.
Representative White, yes.
Representative Sausage.
Unmute.
Oh sorry.
Yes.
Representative Callie Pitts.
Representative Meehan.
Yes.
Representative Oxenham.
Representative Vincent.
Yes.
Representative McGee.
Representative McWilliams.
Yes.
Representative Frieshen.
Representative Pimentel.
Yes.
Representative Pachel.
And the chair, Representative Vose.
The chair votes yes.
21-0.
So with a vote of 21-0, House Bill 410 is retained.
I now call on Representative Bernardi to make a motion about House Bill 543.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I make a motion that we retain House Bill 543.
Chair recognizes Representative Homelope.
Chair, I second that motion was retained House Bill 543.
It has been moved and seconded that we that we retain house bill 543 is there any discussion Seeing none, I ask the clerk to call the roll on the motion to retain House Bill 543.
Okay, and House Bill 543.
This comes right.
One thing.
It's a little first and second.
Right now.
Okay, on the retaining of 543, Representative Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Harrington.
Representative Nada.
Yes.
Representative Murnie, yes.
Representative Homola.
Yes.
Representative Bresni.
Representative Bernadette.
Yes.
Representative Kimbrills.
Representative Ploge.
Yes.
Representative White.
Representative Somsich.
Yes.
Representative Callie Pitts.
Representative Meehan.
Yes.
Representative Oxenhay.
Representative Oxenham.
Yes.
Representative Vincent.
Representative McGee.
Yes.
Representative McWilliams.
Representative Keishin.
Yes.
That's what I said.
You said Keishin.
Yes.
That's what I said.
You said Keishin.
Yes.
Kishin.
Kishin, that's what I said.
You said Kishin.
Kishin.
Remember Kishin formula.
In any case, yes.
Representative Pimentel.
Yes.
Representative Passam.
And the Chair.
Representative Vos.
Chair chair representative votes chair votes yes 21 nothing by a vote of 21 to nothing house bill 543 is retained the chair now recognizes uh representative homola for a motion on House Bill 382.
Yes, Chair, thank you.
I make a motion to retain House Bill 382.
The chair recognizes Representative Bernardi.
Excuse me?
Last session.
Excuse me.
House Bill 382 was heard on friday yes and we voted 21.
it's already voted we did vote that one yes i forgot to write it down on my sheet it was voted 21.
yep yes yes i withdraw the motions thank you 10.45 a.m.
20.00.
Chair?
So I guess I forgot that right?
We understand that.
Representative McGee, did you have a question?
Yes, I'd like to make a motion.
What's the motion?
I'd like to make a motion to retain House Bill session for each bill.
I't open an exec session for hb 394.
so the members we can't uh we can't come from you.
It's not from the chair.
Oh, OK.
It hasn't been opened yet.
Hasn't been opened.
We didn't, I did not open HB 394 for exact session.
That's true.
I was trying to figure out what we did on Friday that I forgot to write down.
410 was today, Mr.
Chair.
For example, we did an executive session and I just made a motion.
So it's a pending motion in exact session.
We voted on a bill today as well as one from Friday.
We retained 169, 20 to 1.
Did we retain 169?
Yes, we did.
We ended up doing a, 20 to one.
Did retain 169?
Yes, we did.
We ended up doing a retaining 20 to one.
Yes.
The only thing we did in build on was 614.
That was the last one of the day.
Yeah, we didn't get the 614.
Why don't we do HB, I'll open an exec session on HB 614.
I have a question for the chair.
Yes, Representative Galevich.
Question is, if the bill was done prior, it's not noticed in the calendar for executive session, can we exec it on another day, just pull it out of the hat and exec it?
Yes, you can call exec session at any time.
I understand that, but if it's not noticed, if that bill is not noticed, it says in here that executive sessions can be called throughout the meeting by, you know, so can we just exec something or do we have to put it on the calendar?
That is a good question.
I'm pretty sure we can just exact bills as necessary.
I can remember in past years we've had exec sessions where we did seven or eight bills and they were not listed on the calendar.
Okay, I'm just wondering.
Thank you.
Any questions?
Jennifer, I'm going to ask you a question.
Yes.
Do you know, as our committee researcher, if we need to call an exec session for a bill on the same day that the bill is, that the public hearing for the bill occurs?
Or if we do it on a different day, does it have to be listed in the calendar do you know that the language in the calendar says executive session on pending legislation may be held throughout the day time permitting from the time the committee is initially convened so any pending legislation legislation would imply that it could be any bill from any day, correct?
That is my understanding.
It doesn't really say that.
The question is what does the last clause modify?
Why does it have that remark in there about from the opening of the day?
That language?
I don't know.
That language came from the clerk.
Muddies the water.
Not sure exactly what that means.
Maybe held throughout the day, time permitting, from the time the committee is initially convened.
So I think that means that you can start the day with an executive session, or you can do an executive session three times during the day.
That would be my interpretation.
And would that bring us back to the pending motion on the floor?
No.
Not until we resolve the issue about opening and closing each executive session.
It's not one executive session?
Apparently not.
Because I did open an executive session on 394.
Yes, Representative Nutter.
We can also call Paul for clarification.
But I remember from previous years they opened and closed each session.
And I think you did forget a couple times.
And that's like I kind of thrown off like, wait, what?
How did we get to the next vote?
So you do have to close.
We're going to close.
Open and close.
We can't hear that.
Is that correct?
Yes.
So do we have to go back and redo then?
No.
410 and 543?
How would that vote be?
Well, we've already voted now, so.
Well, since the votes were unanimous, I'm going to assume that even though I made a mistake on that, which I apologize for, we can go forward with the decision we made on those bills.
Is there any objection to that?
Representative Somsich?
Now, Kat.
No, I don't object.
You're OK with that.
Thank you.
OK, then I'll open an exec session on HB 614.
And Representative Thomas will make a motion.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Representative Harrington is recognized for a motion.
Excuse me, I have a little trouble hearing what was that?
You're recognized for an emotion, for a motion.
On what bill?
I move that we amend HB 614 with amendment number 2021-0156H.
Okay, so moved.
Chair recognizes Representative Thomas.
Second.
So it's been moved and seconded that we uh amend hb 614 with amendment number 2021-0156h which was sent to all of your legislative email Thursday, 2020-21-0156H.
So, do we have any discussion, Representative Somsich?
Sorry, Mr.
Chairman, I didn't lower my hand before.
I didn't have it up.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Representative Medina.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
So I think everyone should probably refer to this amendment before we vote to accept it because it materially changes the bill in a significant way, I think, in terms of the exemptions that it now provides from system benefits charge.
So I don't know if Representative Harrington wants to speak to it or is it or is this your bill, Chairman Bowes?
I don who presented this your bill yes I submitted this amendment we've been over it extensively during the public hearing last Friday if you have a specific question I'd be happy to answer it um actually we did not because I read it I read I read the some of the amendments to bring people's attention to the fact that the amendment you had mentioned that the amendment had removed the language around the alternative compliance payment I believe but you neglected to mention that B and C under the new amendment provided further exclusions from providers of electricity being able to be subject to the compliance payments.
And also that all competitive electricity suppliers shall negotiate with any service, political subdivision, or state agency a contract that provides a rate that excludes costs of compliance with the renewable portfolio standard under RSA 362-F.
So this is a huge change to the ability of the state to secure any funding for energy efficiency, and it would also have a downstream impact on the energy efficiency docket and three-year plan that's pending.
So it's a very significant monetary change to the economy, the energy economy, and I think people ought to know that and know what they're voting for before we move forward with rushing this amendment.
First of all, let me just say that you are not correct about what you just said.
the language of section B, providers of electricity shall not be subject to compliance, et cetera.
That came directly from the public facilities commission.
And it refers back to paragraph A.
And it basically just says that regulated utilities like Eversource, Humatill, are not set, shall exempt basically political subdivisions from compliance under RSA 362.3.
So that's not anything new.
That was the original intention of the bill.
It just wasn't worded very well until the Public and Coordination Commission provided this language.
And then Section C about competitive electricity suppliers was added to the bill because the PUC pointed out that they don't regulate competitive electricity suppliers.
And therefore, if this bill is going to apply to them, and many political subdivisions do buy their electricity from competitive electricity suppliers, including the state of New Hampshire, then this new language would be necessary to get them to comply with the exemption that the bill provides.
So that's why this language was added to the amendment, because it actually allows the bill to do what it originally intended to do.
And the language came from the public.
I'm sorry, Mr.
Chair, but I don't, I don't, I'm reading the words and it's basically saying if a subdivision decides that they're not going to pay the system benefits charge, then the electricity provider can also decide that they don't have to pay it either, which means no one pays it, which means it's eliminated.
So that is a significant change in the law.
That's what it says.
So they're asking, the utilities are asking you to make sure that they no longer have to comply with the system benefits charge.
And that's how I read it.
Maybe a concrete example and help explain it.
So let's say the town of Bepping chooses not to take advantage of section d and by a majority vote of its governing body collects to continue payments it wants to in fact be exempt from making payments its provider is eversource what this bill does is it allows Eversource to essentially subtract from its load the kilowatt hours that the town of Epping would use over the course of a year.
So at the end of the year, when it computes the number of kilowatt hours that it must report to be in compliance with the RPS RSA32F3, the kilowatt hours from Epping are excluded.
That's essentially what that language says.
Yes, and it translates to exactly what I said, which is that it means that neither of them will pay the compliance.
It gets shifted and then eliminated, which is the opposite of what the original legislation, it undoes the legislation that as it stands today.
It undoes the requirement.
What do some divisions pay the RPS?
Representative Pementel, we're recognized for a comment.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The original legislation, the intent of the original legislation, was to fund energy efficiency programs.
And this bill circumvents that and will, in effect, reduce the amount of money for energy efficiency programs.
So it's totally counter to the original purpose of the bill, of the legislation.
Thank you, Representative Sonsich.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I want to echo the comments made by Representative McGee and the others.
that this is a way of reducing the funding that's available for energy efficiency programs, while at the same time allowing entities who don't pay into it to be able to benefit from energy efficiency programs.
Yeah, that would be nice if we could all do that.
We don't have to pay for it.
We just get it for free.
Now, our generation of those over 20 usually are used to paying our own way.
We don't expect free to be the norm.
But this is a way of getting a free deal without having to pay for it.
That's pretty outrageous.
And it does go contrary to the intentions of the original legislation.
In fact, it goes contrary to the governor's 10-year energy plan.
It goes contrary to the state's energy report, which just came out.
Everything that we discuss here in this bill is going the opposite direction.
So I think it's a bad bill.
We heard testimony from a number of energy producers saying that this would hurt them, local New Hampshire generators.
So I think we should not agree to pass this.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative Oxenam.
Thank you for taking my question, Mr.
Chair.
It's, we don't have any, I understand there's an FN, there's a financial note on the bill, but with the amendment, we have nothing that updates us as to the consequences of this decision were we to pass it.
Am I understanding that correctly?
I'm pretty sure that the folks who did the financial fiscal note, I'm pretty sure the folks who did that did not see this amendment.
So no, you're correct i have not evaluated follow-up i The fiscal note, I'm pretty sure the folks who did that did not see this amendment.
So no, you're correct.
They have not evaluated that.
Follow up?
Follow up.
I know on Friday that you made the surprising statement that the money doesn't matter.
But it really does matter enormously if what we're doing here, if we're taking this action without knowing the fiscal and financial consequences.
So I cannot support the bill, the amendment to the bill.
Thank you.
I can't let that statement go unchallenged.
I never said the money doesn't matter.
Obviously, it matters to the taxpayers.
I think the reference was with regard to something i said about the approximately five million dollar cost of this bill as being the equivalent of a coffee cup of coffee a day and a lot of people have asserted that the five million dollars in an earlier bill, it was roughly a couple copies a day, didn't matter.
I was equating it to those things.
I wasn't saying it didn't matter myself.
Okay, so is there anyone else who would like to speak on this bill?
Representative Somsich, I assume your hand is still up from earlier or not.
Thank you.
on this bill?
Representative Somsich, I assume your hand is still up from earlier or not.
I'm saying Representative Foxenner.
Yes.
Can you hear me?
Excellent.
You made the comment when we were talking about the SEC bill.
You did not make that comment with reference to this, but I'm still surprised by the concept when we're talking about any bill that one would say that the money didn't matter.
But we'll let that pass.
Do the chair recognize as Representative Bernardi?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
This is just a point of clarification.
My understanding of this amendment is essentially is some perfecting language to make sure that the bill is well understood.
But the fundamental principle here and the fiscal consequences of this is about $5 million is going to be saved from the state and municipal taxpayers and that's the objective of the bill and the amendment just makes that very clear you might correct that assessment yes it is exactly the intention of the amendment was to clarify the purpose of the bill.
Representative McGee.
Um, I think that that may be how folks are understanding the bill, but in terms of what the bill actually does to Representative Oxenham's point, we do not have an understanding of the economic impact to the RPS programs and to energy efficiency in general if this bill is passed, because what it does is it allows municipalities to take a pass and say, we don't want to pay any money for that anymore.
So those programs that the state is trying to help lower everyone's bills with, we're not going to contribute to it.
And if they decide that they're going to pass on it, then their providers, meaning the utilities in this case, will also be able to waive that charge.
And other electric providers, it appears in the next section, will also have to deduct that charge.
So what we're doing is we're eliminating a significant funding source for a program that benefits all rate payers.
That's how I understand the bill.
And although we can say, yes, it's this, yes, it's that.
If what I am saying is not correct, then this is the time for us to discuss that.
Because we haven't discussed what our aim is with this bill.
But what I'm saying is the consequence of the bill appears to be that we are going to be cutting off our own noses.
We're going to be hamstringing the state to be able to lower costs for people, which was the whole idea behind the RPS in the first place.
Okay, thank you.
I'm going to take a brief time out here, and I am going to open the public hearing on House Bill 153, and immediately call a recess until we finish this executive session.
Does anybody else have any comments to make?
Yes, indeed.
Representative Oxen.
Yes.
Unfortunately, this year, we did not have any orientation specifically directed to the energy efficiency policies of the state.
We didn't get a thorough grounding in RGGI or RPS.
As a result, people are not, don't have the capability to understand what this bill is doing.
In particular, every, we have a cost benefit analysis requirement for any energy savings, energy efficiency work.
And in general, for every dollar that's spent, it's $4 gained.
So when you're taking away the money from these programs, which are the negawatts, the best way for us to be not wasting energy, not polluting for no reason, getting houses made safer, healthier, more comfortable.
All of these programs that are part of state policy, you're saying, oh, let's take the money away because it's going to save the municipals some tax money.
You're very, very much what Representative McGee said.
You're cutting off your nose to spite your face.
You're taking away our primary lever for moving forward.
It's a short-sighted measure with, you know, we're going to lower your taxes.
I find it unfathomable that we're proceeding with this as if this was just business as usual.
This is demolishing a major element of the governor's program of state policy.
You're taking away the money.
You can't do the programs if you don't have the money.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
My understanding, the principle and body here is very similar to the same principle as the state police or any other folks buying gas.
They are exempt from paying the gas tax.
This is the same concept as we are exempting the state and municipalities from the consequences of paying the gas tax.
This is the same concept as we are exempting the state and municipalities from the consequences of paying these payments.
But in principle, everyone else is paying.
So that's the concept that's on the table.
And that's the concept.
I believe you're trying to.
That is correct.
Representative Cretien.
Mr.
Chair, just on that last point about making this analogous to the gas tax, I don't think that that's accurate based on the testimony that we heard on Friday.
We heard that it's much more challenging to untangle who qualifies for this discount and who would not adding a substantial burden actually to the people who are calculating this.
I also, I guess, just wanted to make the point that we heard the argument that we are returning money to the taxpayers so that they can decide how they want to spend that money.
I think in passing the original legislation, we are reflecting that our constituents do want to spend their money on programs like energy efficiency and energy savings.
And that's why they elected us to represent them to do that.
It's not something that you can do with a dollar a month, these big projects.
And it's just ridiculous to me that we're, I don't know, I feel like we're in dereliction of our duty to come together as a group representing the people of New Hampshire and get things done that the people can't do on their own.
That's what government is for.
Thank you, Representative Saussure.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I want to just add to what was said about the impact of this bill.
First of all, it is true that because we don't have an updated fiscal note on the amendment of consequences, it's hard to estimate exactly what's going to happen.
However, this is not just about eliminating a certain amount of money from a pot that's being used for energy efficiency.
Yes, it is true that short-term municipalities and other entities could have a small fiscal gain from this.
But long-term, they will have a bigger negative impact fiscally compared to what they're doing now, and that is subscribing to energy efficiency and renewable energy projects.
Those projects currently are oversubscribed.
More people want to do that and municipalities want to do it than we can support.
And as was mentioned, every single project is scrutinized heavily to see if in a cost-benefit analysis, do we get more benefit than it costs us?
And only if it does get more benefit than cost is it approved.
So to say, let's cut back that funding so we can save a little money now, we're not going to gain those savings and benefits if we don't invest.
In fact, this is all about investing versus spending.
There's a big difference.
You go to the casino in Las Vegas with $1,000 and you lose it all and you get nothing for it.
You take that $1,000 and invest it in energy efficiency, you're going to get savings, monetary savings for the next 20 years from that.
That's an investment.
That's not a spending issue.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative.
As we discussed, I think it was probably either in one of the orientation sessions we had or possibly last Friday.
This whole Zoom format or holding public hearings, this hybrid format, is a learning experience for all of us.
And one of the things that I just recently learned just in the last few minutes is that there's no good way to distribute amendments to the general public who is listening in Thank you.
there's no good way to distribute amendments to the general public who is listening in on this public hearing and executive session as a result they're totally in the dark about what the amendment contains and i don't necessarily think that's a good situation And it's one of the limitations of this format that is causing, I think, a major problem.
So I'm going to recess this executive session until we can figure out a way to distribute the amendment more widely to people so that people can know what's going on.
I'm also going to try to get a fiscal analysis of the amendment if that's possible.
I'm not sure it is, but we'll give it a try.
So we'll recess this executive session until our next meeting, which is probably February the 8th.
But before I do that, I'll recognize Representative Michael Harrington for a comment.
Mr.
Chairman, I'll just wait for the woman to come back.
There's no, I can hold my comments.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I didn't understand.
You'll wait for what?
I don't, I, I'll just wait until we, we, we come back up on this one.
Since you're going to recess it, I I'll just hold my comments until we bring the bill up again.
Oh, okay.
I understand.
All right.
So let's, I'm going to recess and reconvene the public hearing on house bill 153.
And I'm going to call on the prime sponsor of HPB 153, Representative Oxen, I'm gonna introduce the bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
We're now at 2.11.
Is it my understanding that we will have enough time for this bill or will we be cut off when we reach three o'clock?
Do you know how many people wish to speak?
Well, we have seven people signed up to speak.
So if you could introduce it briefly, that would be gratefully appreciated.
Okie dokie.
I don't think I have to tell anyone how important broadband is.
We've all experienced over the past year the fact that to get to work, for your kids to go to school, to have telemedicine, to have emergency services, we have to have good quality, high speed broadband.
And it needs to be available to every resident of the state.
Just as a century ago, we pushed out rural electrification.
We need to be proactive in making sure that New Hampshire is welcoming to businesses who want to move their operations here.
They won't come if they can't have guaranteed access to high-speed internet.
We want a young cohort.
If we want a new demographic moving into our state, we have to be able to provide high-speed quality broadband and internet.
So recognizing broadband expansion is critical.
It's not only an issue for rural areas.
In urban areas, we have broadband deserts where, because of affordability, because of the language, for a variety of reasons, there are obstacles to the proper expansion of broadband.
Municipal governments, business establishments lack the infrastructure for connectivity.
Rural areas, we spoke about the problem of low population density.
Companies don't want to go those extra miles for very few residences.
Why then should we have a study committee?
What will that get us?
In speaking with the companies that provide the service, I was informed that they really want to get a stakeholder session together where we can talk across the table and come to a negotiated settlement, but come to a meeting of the minds about how best to go forward so we don't waste money, so that we operate efficiently, and we get the service into the hands of the people who need them as possible as fast as possible right now in my town the plainfield we have tesla's satellite starlink is is coming in the new hampshire electric cooperative is bringing fiber across the state are those things going to interconnect are are they going to is it going to pose an issue if one goes forward while the other one is not?
Getting everyone into the room makes a lot of sense.
If this were a regulated industry, the PUC would be the ideal place to do this in an investigatory docket, but it's not regulated.
And so the only opportunity to bring the different parties to the table, municipalities, businesses, the companies that are the providers, would be through a study committee.
And so that's what I have produced here.
And I, please, pardon me for misspeaking.
I picked up this bill when Representative Ken Wells, unfortunately, was not reelected.
This was Ken's bill.
And Ken, I'm sure, is waiting patiently to get on the line and tell you much more about why it needs to go forward.
And so I will cede my extra minutes as so-called sponsor to the actual sponsor if the chair is willing to make that available.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative Voxenum.
So it is your desire that I next recognize Ken Wells to speak on behalf of this bill?
I ask that you do so, yes, thank you.
All right, I recognize Ken Wells to speak on behalf of the bill.
And Mr.
Wells, you are- Thank you very much, Chairman Vose, and honorable members of the Science, Technology, and Energy Committee.
Thank you in advance for a few minutes of your kind attention.
I hope that you all have received my written testimony and have it before you.
I sent it to you via email on Friday.
New Hampshire can boast that about 88% of its households have smartphones or computers with internet access.
However, the unserved 12% remainder represents 78,000 households in New Hampshire with zero internet access.
Full high-speed broadband access is unavailable to 23% of rural households and may be unavailable to more than 80% of the residents in some New Hampshire towns.
Even in New Hampshire's urban areas, low-income and minority neighborhoods frequently lack sufficient high-speed bandwidth to meet demand.
I'm going to focus right now on the rural aspect of this problem.
Today, towns must go it alone for universal broadband acquisition.
The existing RSA 53G creates a path for individual towns and their municipal partners to create an entity that can contract for district-wide services, but only on a piecemeal basis.
Each town would have to create its own administrative units, possibly beginning with their existing planning committee, which would then create a body called the Communication District, as well as a governing board for the Communication District.
As the law stands now, this effort would have to be duplicated by every other municipality across the state.
The municipalities that most need better broadband, particularly poor and rural communities, will be the least well-equipped to navigate this administrative process successfully.
What's unique about House Bill 153 is that it addresses the administrative obstacles to universal broadband.
Universal broadband access for all New Hampshire households and businesses should be a state policy goal.
The proposed legislation would create a study committee to identify the most effective way to achieve wholesale universal broadband access across the state for every resident of every municipality in New Hampshire, while avoiding the duplicative and redundant administrative mechanism described in RSA 53G.
The newly enacted House Bill 1111 from last session introduced new language into Section 3 of RS 33 Part 3G that essentially says that if an ISP does not respond to a request for information about served locations, within two months the municipality may declare that area to be unserved.
In which case, the municipality may issue RFPs and the ISP is at risk of losing that territory.
So at this point, I'd like to pause and direct your attention to my written testimony, which includes a synopsis of the unwieldy procedure required in current statute.
The bold type within the synopsis represents non-town specific elements that may be shared productively between planning committees, communication districts, and boards of different towns.
It is likely that a study committee will be able to fill in details of how to accomplish this sharing most effectively and bring New Hampshire to a state of universal broadband access.
I'm going to pause right here.
I hope that you have this written testimony in front of you because I'd like to refer to the eight steps that municipalities would have to go through in order to acquire broadband under RSA 53G.
If you look at this list, I'm imagining a local town to me, Salisbury, New Hampshire, with a population of 1,400 whose non-specialist select board is composed of three tradespeople.
There are 43 homes on North Road that lack broadband access of any kind and additional unserved households as that road crosses into the adjacent towns of Andover and West Franklin, just beyond the Salisbury line.
These are all the steps that Salisbury would have to follow.
The select board would have to form an unpaid planning board.
Two, the planning committee would have to seek private or public funding, seek loans or charge fees.
Three, the planning committee would have to engage legal counsel, accountants, engineers, contractors, consultants, other advisors, and paying for those expenses.
And then four, the planning committee will create a communications district, which creates a name and a seal for itself and is empowered to receive money and enter into contracts with ISPs and broadband customers.
Five, the planning committee creates a governing board, which handles the business affairs of the communication districts.
And this is an important point.
That governing board has to create bylaws guiding its municipal members admissions or to or leaving the board and sharing and figuring out how to share those costs and debts even as the board membership changes as towns band together or decide that they want to get out of their agreements.
Then the planning committee has to research all the suitable types of equipment and prepare cost estimates and citing proposals.
And then they plan a draft district agreement which they bring to a vote in their town.
They present it to the Attorney General, revise it if necessary, and then vote on it to enact it.
Now if you're looking at the at the written testimony part of step 3 and all parts 4, 5, and 6 and part of part 7 are not unique to that town.
They would have to be repeated by all 233 towns in the state of New Hampshire and what I'm proposing is that a study committee be formed to figure out how that work can be shared in common across the state and so i would like to stop and answer questions if you have any thank you representative michael harrington is recognized hearing a question.
Representative Harrington, you recognize for a question.
It's on mute.
Okay, Representative Somsich.
Representative Somsich, you recognize our question?
I'm not hearing a question.
Yes.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, former resident Wells.
I think you bring up a really good point that, especially now that we're in the pandemic, We know that the former resident at Wells.
I think you bring up a really good point that especially now that we're in the pandemic, we notice how important this broadband connection is for everybody.
And the chances are good that this is not going to be the first time we're going to see some type of pandemic or virus affect our state and other places.
So I think it's really good to think about how to make sure that all residents do get access.
So my question to you is, this study committee, or this is, yeah, it's a study committee.
Have you had any contact with organizations or entities that may be involved in making this happen?
For example, have you talked to the current broadband utilities to see if they would be willing to come to some kind of mutual agreement to fill in the holes between coverage?
Yes, thank you for that question.
I have spoken to some of the ISPs in the state, but certainly not all of them.
One of the difficulties that I've run into is that in this town, Salisbury, near me, the town is cut in half by an old telecom territory border that separates one half of the town is in consolidated jurisdiction and the other half is in TDS.
TDS, you might be aware, is headquartered in Wisconsin.
The difficulty is that the territory on the west side of the Merrimack River, which is consolidated, has no fiber service at all.
Consolidated has not brought fiber across the river.
And so it would be prohibitively expensive for them to do that.
And they've proposed a territory swap with TDS.
TDS has not responded to that.
I think that it's really important that the state of New Hampshire takes a role in this, because if the state does not take a role, then not all of the stakeholders or ISPs will be included in this.
And so I think that's very important that the state plays this central role.
The other reason that the state needs to play a central role is in a worst case scenario, we could end up with a patchwork of independent, incompatible, and obsolescent technologies in every different town.
And so I think that there really needs to be, the state needs to come in and say, you know, we want broadband and we want it as soon as possible, within the next few months if possible.
And I think it's going to take statewide organization in order to figure out what the plan is.
So this is why I think a study committee is a good idea, because we need an entity that's empowered and also broad enough in its scope across the state that it can make decisions and make recommendations on how we should proceed best on this.
Thank you, Representative Weld.
Thank you, Representative Michael Harrington.
Do you have a question?
Representative Jackie Kelly-Bitz.
Don't forget to unmute.
Nice to hear from you again, Representative Wells.
Are you aware of any of the committees within the state, telecommunications committees and oversight committees, broadband oversight committees that are doing anything currently to bring this together or try to bring the entities together?
No, I'm not aware that there is any engagement on this under the mechanism that is described in RSA 53G.
It's very well spelled out, I think.
But the problem is, it's such an involved process for a small community, because the number of specialists that you need to hire, the amount of money that you have to be able to put up front.
And I was just talking yesterday to a city councilwoman from Franklin, and I asked her to look at RSA 53 and she said, oh my goodness, this is much more than even a small city can manage to do, never mind a village.
And we really need, especially from my point of view, I live in a rural district.
I understand the rural difficulties, and I hope we're going to have a speaker today talking about what the urban aspect of this is.
But it's everywhere in the state.
And it's not just that it's a uniformly distributed bunch of people who don't have internet access.
There are actual blocks Thank you, Ken.
Thank you.
I would remind everyone that this is a study committee bill, and so the questions should revolve around why we need a study committee.
Next up is Representative Pimentel.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Former Rep.
Wells.
This sounds like it's not that different than electricity.
And I'm wondering if one of the things that they would be looking at is something similar to what we're dealing with with electricity where we have one entity maintaining the distribution system and then the actual services is competitive throughout.
Yeah, so I think that there are a bunch of different ways you could do this, certainly with electricity.
You know, this is how we ended up with a public utilities commission and so forth.
You know, this is very much up to the negotiations with the internet service providers and the state to figure out whether we change the relationship or whether we're able to achieve universal broadband under the current structures.
But I think it's really critical that we do something very soon because we have one in eight of the children in our schools are not able to equally participate in hybrid classrooms because there's there's not adequate broadband for them to participate in a zoom meeting like this one you know they can they can raise their hand but their their audio or video drops out, or they don't have enough data minutes on their cell phone plan.
This is not acceptable.
It's not just our children, it's our seniors.
There are so many isolated seniors, particularly out in the rural areas here, that they can't Zoom with their families to join a birthday party or these other things.
And so they're alone and they don't have any way of reaching out the way that we are doing now during the pandemic.
And so I think this is something we need to deal with very quickly.
If you look at the bill, it identifies stakeholders, including the ISPs, including experts on broadband, including experts on digital equity and inclusion, including experts on finance and things like that, grant writers and so forth.
So I'm thinking that this study committee could be a model for the type of entity that would be able to marshal all the resources that communities need.
Okay, thank you, former Representative Wells, for your testimony.
We have five other people who would like to testify on this bill, so I will now call on Representative Suzanne Vail.
Suzanne Vale.
Representative, you are now able to speak.
Remember to unmute yourself.
Can you hear me now?
Yes, we can.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm sorry about that.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Chairman and honorable colleagues.
My name is Suzanne Vail, and I'm a state representative from Nashua Ward 3, Hillsborough District 30.
I rise today in support of the bill.
As you heard from the Honorable Ken Wells, lack of broadband infrastructure is a statewide problem in isolation and being disconnected occurs in the city even as far as interfering with some, the ability to survive in the home.
When our schools went to virtual learning in response to the pandemic, cable broadband became available to more students in Nashua Thank you.
the ability to survive in the home.
When our schools went to virtual learning in response to the pandemic, cable broadband became available to more students in Nashua under the Comcast Internet Essentials program.
And that was expanded due to the state of emergency and it brought broadband into a lot of homes for a low price.
But this level of service and bandwidth is very slow and it doesn't support multiple students simultaneously.
It's supposed to be a certain rate of megabits and it measures most of the time at 17 or less.
The speed and the instability is too much for even the rest of the customers in the city who are using the broadband for their entertainment home and the delay is distributed out over everyone.
We don't have a lot of options in Nashua in terms of broadband as consolidated communications, installed fiber optic service in some parts of our town, but never extended the opportunity to the rest of the city.
Instead of going into the details about all the things that you need to do, that you need to have a computer in order to do, I will leave that and yield some of my time.
But I do want to say that our community mental health center and our public health center, our domestic and sexual violence catchment areas served by Nashua.
We have a lot of obligation out there that we need to keep an eye on people in the community.
We need to extend the services to them that they're entitled to.
And we as providers of services and as outreach, people, whether in government or providing human services, we are really severely handicapped from providing the services that we can do.
And so I just wanted to speak up on the urban impact because it may not be so obvious that the problems we face are similar and different, but we have serious problems just as much as the rest of the state.
And when it's time to consider a solid and time-tested approach, I urge you to bring us a step closer to installing universal broadband in New Hampshire by forwarding this bill down to the vote for a unanimous floor vote.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms.
Vail, for your testimony.
I have Senator Jay Kahn signed up to speak.
However, I do not see no list.
People have requested to speak from the attending panel.
I'll skip over him for now to see if he shows up later.
And next I will call on Carol Miller, who I have seen on the list.
And Ms.
Miller, you are now allowed to speak.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Chairman Vos and the members of the Science, Technology, and Energy Committee.
I'm providing testimony in support of HB 153, in part, for a couple of reasons.
You have my written testimony, so I won't spend a whole lot of time going through the usual statements about broadband.
But I just will introduce myself to new committee members.
I'm currently serving as Director of Broadband Initiatives for the National Collaborative for Digital Equity.
Thank you.
introduce myself to new committee members.
I'm currently serving as Director of Broadband Initiatives for the National Collaborative for Digital Equity, founded and based in New Hampshire, newly retired on December 31st from state government as the Director of Broadband Technology in the Department of Business and Economic Affairs, and formerly DRED in the Division of Economic Development, combined with over 11 years in state service.
Previously spent 19 years as Vice President of North Country Internet Access based in Berlin, New Hampshire, and currently speaking from my home in Gorham, New Hampshire, in Cohos County.
I've spent most of my career helping people connect to the Internet, and, you know, there are gaps everywhere.
This is not our first time in a study committee bill.
I conducted the last study committee for a group, I would say, four years ago.
And I'm supporting this bill not necessarily to create a statewide network.
It's to bring the partners together.
I'm supporting this bill, not necessarily to create a statewide network.
The bill is written in a way that when I listen to what former Representative Wells was talking about, it seems like we're putting the cart before the horse.
We need to go back through and look at the landscape.
Look what's happening.
Who is in a position to be able to move broadband forward?
The state has never been in the business of broadband.
In fact, they've been hands-off for the 11 years that I have been in state service.
There's current legislation introducing establishing a broadband initiative matching fund.
And I testified this morning that they need to really establish an office of broadband first before they come up with a fund.
And I think the Office of Strategic Initiatives is the perfect place to do that.
So there are lots of things swirling around that we don't know about.
And I think in order for any recommendations to come out of this committee, and I'm more than happy to serve, I think it's a great idea.
But I don't want to get to the end of a study committee like we did last time and nothing happened.
Nothing.
Not a one thing happened.
It was very disappointing in a number of ways.
We spent months presentation after presentation from providers.
At the time, New Hampshire Electric Co-op came in and presented.
They weren't getting into the business of broadband.
Today, they've just spent $12 million putting in fiber to the premise.
So there's a lot going on in the state.
And I think that it's time that we look at strategies to look to the future.
Stop worrying about the present.
We can't fix the present.
What we can do is fix the future.
We can future-proof New Hampshire.
We can do fiber to every premise in the state.
I don't care who owns it.
I don't care who manages it, but it should be available to each and every constituent across the state.
In my testimony, I tell you, historically, business has always been able to secure fiber to the premise.
It's the residential market that has been ignored.
And to the fact that it's been allowed to, the old infrastructure has been allowed to deteriorate.
We need new wire, new fiber, new competition, whatever it takes.
And I think we have an opportune time now to come up with strategies and embrace the future for the next 50 years to come.
Stop putting band-aids on a sagging infrastructure and let's look for new infrastructure of the future.
Providers need capital and partners to expand their fiber nodes.
In my new role, I'm providing guidance to many initiatives, including investment, collaboration for remote content delivery, and developing models for communities in New Hampshire and nationwide for relieving digital inclusion barriers and expressly promoting implications for policymakers.
And the time is right.
Fiber is our future.
It's a long-range plan, but it's the only one that will deliver the capacity that we need now and for the next 50 years.
We have a unique opportunity right now to map fiber as it's being deployed and maintain that data for future investments in every community.
So on that note, I will conclude my testimony.
And again, I am in support of this bill, but the last thing I think anyone wants to do is spend a lot of time and have nothing come out of it.
There's some recommendations that need to be looked at and Thank you for that testimony.
For questions, I see Representative Jackie Calley-Pitts.
Don't forget to unmute.
Hi, Carol.
It's nice to talk to you again.
Would a committee, could a committee be instrumental in securing federal funds?
I know that in Washington, there's a Broadband Act of 2020, and I know that the administration is very interested in promulgating broadband and higher up and down speeds.
So do you think the committee could be instrumental in doing that, in getting funds for the state?
Well, I think the committee could be instrumental in establishing a broadband office.
When I retired December 31st, nobody, you can't call anybody in the state and talk about broadband.
The new legislation is on the broadband matching initiative fund is placing it in the office of strategic initiatives, which I think is great, but there still is nobody in charge of broadband at the state level.
And I think that's one recommendation that we need to come up with.
There are advantages to having a broadband office.
Number one, if you're writing grants, just score higher if you have somebody in state government that is in charge or that understands what's going on in your state.
That person can also be helpful to the federal delegation in regards to what works for New Hampshire when they're proposing these broadband bills that are so big and large.
I mean, they look at New Hampshire at the federal level, and they think we're fairly well connected.
And I guess we are, as opposed to Missouri or Alaska.
But we still have gaps.
And we don't have the infrastructure of the future available to each and every resident.
So there's a lot of work to be done.
And this committee could start us down the path of actually getting organized with a broadband office, with broadband funds, with strategies that help providers and municipalities, whoever it is.
We don't care who owns a fiber.
We just care that it's available and usable and reliable and fast.
So I hope I've answered your question and it's good to see you as well.
Thank you.
Representative Somsich.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Ms.
Miller.
So, apparently, from what I've heard, you are basically a broadband warrior.
But then you also know that New Hampshire likes Band-Aids.
We use Band-Aids all the time for all kinds of problems.
So, and you say yourself that you had, you were on the last study committee, and nothing happened as the result of that.
So while I support this bill and what it's trying to do, I wonder if two things.
I wonder what you think is the most critical thing that they have to tackle in the beginning.
And when will you know when you're on a study committee, this study committee, when it's a waste of time and you might as well stop?
Should you put some certain priorities first?
And if people aren't willing to go along with that, then you might as well not waste two years of a study.
So it's not too encouraging what I hear, which has happened historically, but what do you think needs to happen so this is a serious effort?
Well, I think that the committee needs to look at removing barriers through current legislation that's being proposed that hasn't passed yet, the committee can obviously support that establishing the broadband office with somebody in charge of broadband for the state that can can talk to representatives and senators like yourself and and understand what's happening as opposed to just going off and doing nothing.
I think what scared the last study committee is we know it's going to take some money to do these things.
Things don't come cheap.
I mean, if we want to map New Hampshire for fiber today, we need money to do that and money.
Everything stops at the money conversation.
So maybe with strategies and, and some support from all of these initiatives that are happening all across the state.
Did you know there were three County initiatives looking to do fiber to the premise?
There's Coas County, there's Carroll County, there's Grafton County.
The lady from Nashua or the representative from Nashua spoke about how things were rough in her town.
I mean, the problem is everywhere.
The capacity is stressed.
We need more capacity.
And in order to do that, we need to try collaboratively to remove any barrier we can.
And the committee can do that.
I don't think the committee is a waste of time.
And I don't think the last committee was a waste of time.
I said I was disappointed.
There's a big difference there.
I learned a heck of a lot.
And you can bet that today, New Hampshire Electric Co-op is in the broadband business because they were hauled into that meeting.
And all of a sudden, the light bulb went off, and then funding became available.
So there's a lot to be done from collaboration and talking about these things.
Low and middle income people don't have the same access to digital hardware or computers.
We have programs that we've begun in cities like Manchester, Project Lemonade, which is putting devices into hands of these underprivileged families.
We have programs through some providers that provide, and again, it may not be the right capacity, but maybe with pressure from this committee, we can up the ante and get more capacity for these internet essentials programs, these discounted programs for low and middle income students or families with children in the school system.
And even for senior citizens, there are programs for senior citizens.
So with some pressure and some recommendations, we could possibly help.
But if we don't meet and we don't get together, we don't convene, we don't meet and we don't get together we don't convene we don't collaborate we don't do anything so little steps a long range plan and keep your eye on the future follow up mr chairman yes representative samsich can i just point out before you ask a follow-up question Thank you.
Follow-up, Mr.
Chairman?
Yes, Representative Somsich, can I just point out before you ask a follow-up question that we have two more people who would like to speak on this bill, and then we have an extensive lineup of people who want to speak on the next bill and the bill after that.
So just keep that in mind as you- I will be very brief, Mr.
Chairman.
Okay, thank you.
Mr.
Miller, I just wanted to ask, you mentioned the money.
Do you think that some seed money upfront would be a big incentive?
I think it would be very helpful if we need to buy intelligence or data or need to help collaborate someone.
Some seed money up front might do well, and that might do well to go to the Office of Strategic Initiatives, because they're going to need to spend that money and to do mapping and whatever else needs to be done and collaborate.
And I'll leave my comments there.
I tend to be long winded, so I will just, I'll stop it there.
But yeah.
Okay, Ms.
Miller, thank you very much for your testimony.
Next person I have signed up to speak on this bill is Jim Isaac, who was a member of the public representing himself.
On my list of speakers here, I have someone named Jim I.
I'm going to take a chance that that's Jim Isaac and allow him to speak to speak.
Go ahead please.
Yes, thank you Chairman Voss.
I also submitted written testimony and given the timing I'm going to let you read that at your leisure and try and address some of the concepts that have come up so far.
I strongly support the study committee.
The reasons I'm advocating this have to do with the need to understand what is going on in New Hampshire at the detailed level, that map that has been described here.
The reality is that we need to take a strategic intent, is the word I would use, to commit to making broadband available to every residence in the state.
What that means I think we're going to have to understand will vary from area to area.
So much of my comments really are tied to the idea that we need to understand what works in Nashville and we understand what works in Co-os County.
In some places it's going to be cable suppliers.
In some places it may be telephone suppliers.
In some places it may be satellite.
In some places it may be municipal.
All of those are capable of helping us solve the problem, but a statewide understanding of the problem and help in coordinating that effort would be very useful.
I've seen some the the obstacles in other states that I've worked with.
The challenge I see for New Hampshire is to develop a commitment to go here and then engage, starting with the local jurisdictions, find out how to make sure they can get what they need.
And I had not realized the kind of issues that representative Wells had raised earlier that you know interfere with the ability for municipalities to actually make their own decisions here and proceed after them but clearly we need to support them as a state if we're going to have the intent of making broadband available so I'm actually going to stop there and answer questions rather than take up more of your time because you already have the written material in front of you.
Thank you very much Mr.
Isaac.
We appreciate your testimony written and verbal.
Next up on the list of testifiers is our last speaker of the day and that's Mara Weston.
She represents the New England Cable and Telecommunications Association.
NECTA is a five-state regional trade association representing substantially all private cable providers in New Hampshire, including Atlantic Broadband, Charter, and Comcast.
Our members serve 104 New Hampshire municipalities with broadband, video, voice, wireless, home security, and automation services.
Over the past decade, our members have collectively invested over a billion dollars developing state-of-the-art networks in New Hampshire to service our now more than 450,000 customers.
I thank you for the opportunity to provide comments today on House Bill 153.
I have submitted written testimony with a significant amount of information about the work our members are doing to provide high-speed broadband and the unprecedented steps they have taken to keep Granite Staters connected, particularly through this pandemic.
As the sponsor said, this pandemic has certainly made clear to all of us the importance of high-speed internet for those of us who work in school from home and want to connect with family.
And our broadband providers, our members, are taking proactive steps to ensure that families and students are not only connected, but that they stay connected.
We have pledged not to terminate service for customers unable to pay their bills.
We have waived late fees, opened up tens of thousands of free Wi-Fi hotspots throughout the state, invested millions of dollars in programs to help low-income individuals get connected.
And we've partnered with municipalities and schools Thank you.
thousands of free Wi-Fi hotspots throughout the state, invested millions of dollars in programs to help low-income individuals get connected, and we've partnered with municipalities and schools to provide subsidized high-speed internet service at no cost to students or their families.
Although NECDA doesn't oppose a study commission or other efforts that thoughtfully address the issue of broadband access, we urge the committee to consider a few points in your deliberations.
First, it is absolutely crucial to have an accurate understanding of the state of deployment and the efforts underway.
This is a critical foundation.
We need a common set of facts.
For example, cable has deployed gigabit service throughout 184 towns and cities in New Hampshire, bringing the state-of-the-art service to, as I said, more than 450,000 customers.
Our deployment, along with that of the rest of the wired industry, has brought broadband speeds to more than 95% of the state.
The issue really before us is how to bring broadband to a remaining small percentage.
The findings in this bill seem to reflect perceived needs, but not necessarily the actual state of broadband, nor does it clearly articulate a problem to be addressed.
Should the committee determine that a commission is worthwhile, NECTA urges this committee to amend the composition of the commission.
As currently formed, there is one industry voice on a 13-member commission, which is truly inadequate to reflect the importance and contributions of stakeholders.
The Broadband industry is comprised of a diverse set of companies deploying different technologies and solutions to meet all their customers' needs.
Any commission should include representation from members of the cable industry, iLEC telephone, RLEC telephone, CLEX, wireless, fixed wireless, and satellite industries.
These companies are already solving the problem of broadband availability and are critical to a successful commission.
We need the right people and the right focus on the right issues if a commission is to be successful.
And with that, I'm happy to answer any questions.
If a commission were to move forward, we would look forward to to working with it and hopefully have an opportunity to participate.
Thank you for your consideration.
Thank you, Weston.
I do have one.
Are you doing work on any provision in this bill if we were to retain this bill?
Representative Thomas, we can't hear you.
We couldn't see that.
We need to have Mr.
Isaac mute.
I don't think I'm unmuted, but I can't.
Oh, maybe I can.
You need to mute this because she's getting feedback.
Didn't solve the problem, unfortunately.
Are you unmuted now or on summer?
Are you muted?
You did now.
It's on strider now.
I'll just restate my question to Ms.
Weston.
Are you willing to work if this bill would be retained on perhaps revising some words to better approach the situations that you're speaking about?
Yes, absolutely.
My clients and I would be happy to work with the committee on that.
Sorry for the quick change of personnel there.
We have almost reached the end of this public hearing.
Are there any outstanding questions for Ms.
Weston from the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you for the opportunity.
I actually do see a couple of hands raised.
Okay, sure enough.
Representative Bernardi, you are recognized for a question.
Thank you for the opportunity.
I actually do see a couple of hands raised.
Okay, sure enough.
Representative Bernardi, you are recognized for a question.
Yes, you made the point we need a common set of facts.
And I think one of the goals of this is universal broadband.
But I think one thing that needs to be considered or you need proper facts on this, there may be some folks that don't want broadband.
There are many elderly want their telephone.
They don't want a flip phone.
They don't want any other kind of phone.
They don't want a computer.
They don't want anything to do with this kind of technology.
That has to be part of the consideration of what you're going to do in these communities, both rural as well as urban.
I absolutely agree with you, Representative.
In fact, there are probably more people in the state who have access to broadband than have computers or smartphones.
Adoption is a significant issue.
Even though people may have access to the service, they choose not to take it.
And that is a significant issue when my clients look at building out as well.
So that's an important part of the conversation.
You raise a good point.
Thank you.
Representative Closier, you have a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Ms.
Weston, for your testimony.
I'm going to work off this to represent or not this comment.
In my family, we have internet.
I did not do research internet broadband I don't even know what we have.
It was quite well and enough.
I got a question coming up.
Now that our children's also live with us now that the grandchildren are out of school, I have been shut down many times because it incapacitated not enough internet my question to you is would this affect the costs that representative bernardi mentioned to people like me who other than this pandemic i don't need it i don't want it and i don't want to, and I don't want it to occur at a cost of either to others that broadband might push onto regular internet.
Would you have a way of making sure that might be taken into consideration?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Sure.
Let me try to respond to your question, and hopefully I'm understanding it correctly.
The first comment that I would make is that taxpayer-subsidized broadband spreads the cost to all, regardless of whether or not they want the service.
For example, a municipal network.
So I think, one, you know, a note of caution there as municipalities invest taxpayer dollars in networks.
Two, my clients have offered services at very much discounted rates through the pandemic and have worked with families to try to address their needs at the lowest cost solution.
In terms of capacity, we are deploying gigabyte service throughout our footprint.
And so there is availability for what you might need during this pandemic.
I'm a working mother and my husband's working from home and I have two kids who are remote schooling.
So I understand full well, you know, having multiple people on multiple Zooms at the same time.
So capacity is something that you can consider for the short term and then, you know, work with the company to obtain a different package when those needs are not, are no longer necessary.
So, So, you know, there are a few points there, and I hope that that helps to address your overall concerns and questions.
Okay, thank you, President.
Thank you.
With that testimony, we're going to have to close this public hearing.
will representative votes i'm sorry for um interrupting it looks like a mr epfelberg has his hand up in the attendees list and he reached out to our office indicating that he'd like to testify well unfortunately we are out of time and have to move on next i'll give him two minutes.
So, Mr.
Apleberg, you have two minutes.
Please go ahead.
Yes, thank you, Chairman Vos.
And I apologize.
I'm not sure why.
I had registered to testify.
I'm not sure why that didn't go through on the site.
But in any case, I will not take two minutes.
My name is Michael Affelberg.
I'm the president of the United Way of Greater Nashua, and I would like to speak in favor of establishing this study committee.
Earlier on, it was discussed the needs of the rural parts of the state with regards to broadband access.
Absolutely understand that.
In our community, since the beginning of the pandemic, our efforts have been to provide wireless or internet access to inner city students and their families who just frankly did not have it because they couldn't afford it.
Even at the level of something like Comcast's internet essentials program, which is only $10 a month, it does come with some barriers for registration.
So we've been distributing Wi-Fi hotspots at some fairly significant expense.
We've had over 400 families reach out to us for that service and have connected thus far over 800 students to the internet as a result of that initiative.
That is not a function of not having an area that has no broadband.
That's a function of being in an area that has no affordable broadband.
And I would encourage the study committee to take that seriously into account.
We need to look at some way to connect kids and families to the internet, even in places where it does already exist.
And that is all that I had to offer.
But I did want to say we really appreciate this effort and would support a study committee and any input that we can give.
Thank you, Mr.
Apsberg.
You did a great job and finished in a minute and 30 seconds.
Thank you very much.
And I apologize to you that your earlier registration did not somehow get through.
I guess it just proves that technology is not perfect.
We will now close the public hearing on HB 153.
I will report that the blue sheet chose 23 people in support of the bill, zero opposed the bill.
And with that, we'll declare that bill closed, that public hearing closed, and we'll open the public hearing on HB 119.
I will ask the time sponsor, Mr.
Representative John Mann, to introduce the bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
House Bill 119.
FN just deletes a kind of messy situation that had come up a few years ago with the legislation about funding for energy efficiency.
Funding for energy efficiency has been for years been funded by the system's benefits charge which is part of your electric bill and the PUC initiated a project called EERS or energy efficiency resource standard Standard.
And when that came up, this bill soon followed, which said the purpose was to say that the legislature would have to approve any increase in the system's benefits charge.
So that was, and that was not justified on any discussion about whether the PUC or the legislature were more capable of doing a good job or had the understanding to govern the issues related to energy efficiency.
It was all about whether the Constitution allowed it.
There was a mistaken reading of the Constitution that was behind the bill.
Bill.
And so somehow that got in there.
And that reading basically said that no increase in the system systems benefit charge can be done without prior approval of the legislature.
Senator Bradley, seeing EERS getting underway, put an additional change in a subsequent change to the language to the effect that postponing this requirement of legislative approval until after the first EERS project got finished.
So I just deleted the the original erroneous change and also deleted the now unnecessary addition by Senator Bradley and restored the language to what it had been before the interference with the EERS.
So that is essentially the bill.
There hasn't been any real debate about whether the PUC or the legislature is more qualified to run the system's benefits charge or make judgments about how to run, how to pay for the energy efficiency.
It was simply an act done and at this point an act deleted.
I will say that we're way behind neighboring states in our energy efficiency work and interference with the Public Utilities Commission in their work on EERS is not going to be helpful.
I looked at my electric bills from 2016 and 2020, that's only four years, and computed the difference in the transmission charge.
And as you know, the transmission charge kind of reflects how much electricity we demand in this state relative to the other states in the region.
And in that four-year period, the per kilowatt hour transmission rate doubled, which is really surprising.
It seems to me the other states in New England must have done an awfully good job on energy efficiency in order to have that result occur.
And it is true that all of our surrounding states do have robust energy efficiency programs.
I've been at meetings where people, where one case, a presentation was given called a report from the donut and the donut represented Massachusetts, Maine Maine and Vermont, our surrounding states.
And the joke was that New Hampshire was the hole.
In another meeting more years ago, I heard one person laugh and say, well, there's plenty of work in Massachusetts.
So that in a sense, we have been kind of somehow not doing, certainly not doing what's possible in the energy efficiency field.
So in a sense, my motivation to this, putting in this bill was not just to correct the the error made a few years ago, but also to get some funding released so we can actually pursue energy efficiency and with all the benefits it has.
I'm very experienced in energy efficiency.
I have an extremely energy efficient house.
I've done some very significant work in my town buildings.
I know what it can do.
The difference you can make is amazing and sometimes the work is quite simple.
And but you do need a good program and it needs to be done forcefully.
So that's the end of my presentation on House Bill 119.
Oh, I wanted to add, excuse me, I wanted to add, and I've said this before, so I just wanted to repeat it.
If you look at, if you have an aggressive energy efficiency program, the amount of of money that gets saved accumulates, you know, constantly.
Because, you know, what the work you did 25 years ago has been producing 25 times as much as what a benefit and savings that you can get done in one year.
What you did 24 years old, 24 times and so on, that adds up to a huge amount of savings and that big chunk of money, that triangle, either goes to our own people or goes to the oil companies.
And we need to get started.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Representative.
Representative.
Representative Somsich is right.
I just want to ask you a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Representative Mann, for your bill.
I'd like to know, is the systems benefits charts the source of the funding for the New Hampshire Saves program?
Well, I think New Hampshire Saves is complicated because it's a brand.
I don't know that it's a program.
It might be a brand for several programs.
It could, I would, I suspect it's, New Hampshire saves is a combination of what, what the RGGI funding provides, as well as what the systems benefit charge would be funding.
In other words, NH saves will be the brand name, even with EERS, for example.
Follow up, Mr.
Chair.
Yes, follow up.
Also, Representative, thank you for taking my question.
And do you have any idea of how many low income households in this state are waiting for energy efficiency measures?
I mean, whether the numbers or what the waiting list is, how many years people have to wait?
No, I have no ideas about that.
I did ask once why there wasn't more advertising for NH saves and one of the reps from one of the employees of LeverSource says, well, if we advertise, we run out of money in a month.
So they don't advertise.
Don't expect it as a whole lot.
And again, it's not as if there's no one capable of doing that work in New Hampshire.
They're all working in Vermont, Maine, and Massachusetts.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Representative, for the question.
I have a question myself.
Representative Mann, I've heard you talk many times before about the wonderful benefits of energy efficiency, and I'm wondering if energy efficiency is so beneficial to so many people, then why aren't those people going out and spending their own money to buy renovations?
Yeah, that's a good question.
Let me think about that.
The cost is not insignificant.
I don't know.
I mean, Massachusetts basically used incentives in a sense that my daughter's house was in a low income area.
And I don't know what kind of low income area, but the person I called said, well, you qualify after I gave my address, my daughter's address.
And she got 75% paid by the state and seven years at zero percent to pay back her remaining portion so that is very proactive work by Massachusetts and you know on bill financing is another way to deal with it, deal with the cost.
As a follow-up, do you think it's possible that people don't spend money on energy efficiency because they choose to spend their money in other ways?
Well, you know, technically or in terms of the verbal logic, absolutely.
But I think the reason to use energy efficiency again is that it creates wealth.
I think the first of all, it creates jobs, plenty of jobs, and good jobs for people that are working with their hands that don't have college degrees.
It leaves more money in the economy.
And again, as I said before, this added wealth in the economy accelerates.
It's a huge thing.
Massachusetts is way, way ahead of us.
And the fact that we pay twice as much for transmission and we're this tiny state with all the industry that's happening in Massachusetts, in Connecticut, Rhode Island, and so on.
It's amazing.
I just sort of discovered this transmission charge thing, but I haven't sort of turned it into an analysis of exactly what the ratio of our consumption of electric power compared to others is.
But I think you do need incentives and you do need to have a program.
The reason to have a program partly is that people want to know that they have a competent and well overseen program, so they're not going to get some hacker making a mess of their house.
That's why state programs are so good.
This is going to be so much on energy efficiency and obtaining benefits from saying, why do you believe that Massachusetts electricity costs 20% more than it?
Probably to pay for the energy efficiency.
But if they use 20% less, it's not a bad deal.
Representative Holmell is recognized for a question.
Yes, Chair.
Thank you very much.
Representative Mann, thank you for taking my question.
The question I do have is, can you tell me what the system benefits charge funds exactly?
I'm sorry?
Yes, sir.
Can you tell me what the system benefits charge funds exactly?
What does it fund?
I don't know exactly.
The intention is that it'll be funding the energy efficiency programs though.
I don't know what else it funds.
I think it may fund some right now, some energy efficiency.
Okay.
The question I have is if we don't know exactly what it funds or if it's not clarified, why would we give the PUC authority to alter this instead of the legislature?
Because the PUC is running these programs.
I guess maybe what would be useful would be a presentation about what's going on with the energy efficiency resource standard.
It's a major project in terms of organizing a statewide energy efficiency program.
And it's kind of we're getting off the dime, you know, essentially.
But I don't know the answer to your question.
I think there are some low income efforts and there are some that are federally funded.
And I don't have a very detailed picture of exactly what's being done.
You you need another follow-up, Representative?
No, no, sir.
I was just commenting that I don't think we were getting off the dime on this.
I think that's the whole point of this.
What's being proposed is to change the authority to change the system benefit chart from the legislature to the CDC.
So I just wanted to comment that that's precisely all the dime.
Okay.
Representative Ploge, you had a question?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Yes, thank you for your testimony.
To follow up, Representative Malawas, the way I see it is the legislature It sets the cost benefit charge and at one time or it still does now it needs it it's the legislator that needs to raise it and this bill takes that away so right now if there was a rate increase, am I correct?
A system charge increase, according to this bill, the voters would have no, the TCU would have no accountability to the voters.
They weren't elected as bureaucrats making increases in charges.
No longer just checking.
Am I correct?
No, I don't think you're correct.
First of all, the voters would hold the legislature responsible if there was excessive money or they thought.
I mean, that's the legislature has an oversight responsibility.
But I think trying to run the details of any part, any program in the state, I mean, our entire administrative state is running on their own, basically with legislative oversight and legislative policy.
Thank you for the explanation.
I want to read more so I better understand, unless you can explain it out where the legislators sets the rate for system benefits, but this bill allows the DUC to increase it?
I think the PUC said it.
We might wanna hear from somebody with the Public Utilities Commission.
I'm quite sure that what the legislature has is oversight, not setting rates.
Thank you.
Okay, next up is representative Crecian.
Sorry, my mistake.
I did not mean to have my head raised.
Okay, next up is representative Vox.
Thank you very much.
It's my understanding that Mike Fitzgerald from DES is on the line who is proficient in these issues and we should be asking him these questions rather than the sponsor of the bill.
Could we possibly ask, we often have done this in the past to have agency personnel when when we don't have the answers i second the motion i second it i think that's a great idea sorry and you'll have to help us here if we have somebody on the phone how do we get them into this meeting is there a phone number?
I don't see anything on my screen.
I'm not even seeing him now.
He might have been called away.
We also have Madeline Minow.
I don't see Karen Crampton here either.
John Kreese is waiting as well.
She'll be speaking after Representative Land.
She's obviously sure.
Barring having the professionals here, if I might just remind people what's in the 10-year energy strategy, could I do that Chair Post?
You have a question to ask Mr.
Manning?
The question was asked earlier as to what the system benefits charge is and what it covers, and I think that there are answers in this document, but there are also policy directives that come out of the governor's office.
The legislation describes the system's benefits charge.
I mean, it's, I can't.
Well, the notion is that it's a charge because what it's providing benefits the entire system.
It's not something that just creates a pool of money that those.
OK, Representative Oxenman, you were not, you were recognized for a question.
So Representative McG are now thank you thank you um i i actually also wanted to mention i think some of the folks are not understanding that the public utilities commission actually has the regulatory power the authority to set rates and so that's what the utilities commission does for us as our agent so we there was it's set up statutorily that we don't have to have the expertise to be working on all of the details of that they do that and so this comes under the that rate setting and i think that's how it is that the authority is best aligned over there with oversight from us, but not taking away every time they want to do something that we have to vote on it, because that is a very cumbersome bureaucratic process.
Is there a question there?
We have a utilities commission.
No, it's actually a clarification because several people had asked why these bureaucrats have this and it's they have that authority because we gave it to them.
That's all I'm trying to say.
That's how it's set up.
That's how it works.
So that's how our national government is set up.
And state all of the states are set up that way.
Well, we're not here to debate this issue, but...
But understanding is important.
People don't understand...
I'm not correct about that, actually.
The system benefits charge used to be specified in statute, and it was only after the EPRS was adopted that the system benefits charge was no longer specified in statute.
So next up is Representative Kelly Pitts.
Representative Mann, I want to try to understand this legislation and I'm going to try to put it back to when I was on the school board.
I remember we used to, you know, we passed the budget and we went in every direction.
And we had about a two and a half hour debate on the size of soccer ball and what size soccer balls we should buy.
Do you think that legislation right now to allow the legislators to set the systems benefits charge would be that kind of a situation where we are legislating small things and not just overseeing what's happening with the electric companies and what's happening with the systems benefits judge we get their report i do believe and i'm going to ask you if you will concur we do get reports annually about what they're doing and if we notice something that we think is out of whack can we call them to account and can the PUC call them to account?
In other words if somebody decided to 250 percent increase the systems benefits charge could we call them to account for that?
We have that already.
Well, we have, you know, the PUC has extensive reports and the EERS is separately extensive reports and it is up to the legislature if we care to pay attention to review those reports.
May I follow?
Yes, follow up.
Thank you.
reports.
May I follow?
Yes, follow up.
We have an electric utility restructuring committee, which became the electric utility oversight committee.
Do you believe that overseeing some of the things that go on that we were afraid might happen belongs in that committee?
Yeah, I would say that committee or one like it, but I think that committee, you know, it's all a matter of how much scope of subject matter they want to cover it, whether you have that committee or another one like it.
But I think it's a good I think that's a fine way to do the oversight is to have a group of legislators that can look at a report that's 50, 100 pages long and understand what it means.
Thank you.
Representative Nader is recognized for a question.
Representative Nauter is recognized for a question.
Thank you.
Is the assistance benefit charge voluntary or mandatory?
It's on your bill and you have to pay it, yes.
Well, it's not voluntary.
You can turn off your electric power, but that's it.
Okay, thank you.
Next up would be Representative Oxidam.
Yes, thank you very much for taking my question.
If I might be permitted to just clarify this issue about the system benefit charge, the reason it's on your bill is because this is money which is collected from all ratepayers that is invested in our energy system and reduces the amount of money that we have to pay, all of us, because we're able to invest in things that reduce waste and allow us to have lower peaks so that we don't have to build out more transmission.
We're talking hundreds of millions of dollars in savings.
That's on page 23 of the 10-year report.
And also $160 million added to New Hampshire's gross domestic product annually.
When we invest the money so that we do things better and more efficiently, we save money, we grow jobs, we grow the economy.
Cutting this system's benefit charge does more than cut off our nose.
It's cutting off our heads.
Is there a question there, Representative?
No, and I asked at the outset if I could make a statement to clarify because I felt that we weren't getting to the nub of what the system benefits charge is, and that was a question that was raised earlier.
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Sockeson.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And thank you, Representative Mann, for taking my question.
And my question is this to you.
Does this definition sound familiar to you?
Part of the electric bill that is designated to be used for funding statewide energy efficiency initiatives grants to insulate low and middle income housing and assistance to low income customers in meeting their energy expenses.
Yes, although I would hope that we would, yes, that's pretty much.
That's the SBC definition here.
Yeah, but I would think, I would hope that we would.
Yes, that's pretty much.
That's the SBC definition here.
Yeah, but I would think I would hope that in the long run, we'd substitute energy efficiency for rate relief for the low income people.
I'm just reading from the definition.
That doesn't imply that some of the low-end, low-income housing is actually suitable for actually making more efficient.
Some of the mobile homes may be really difficult.
Sure, granted.
Thank you.
We have two other people who would like to testify.
So I would like to now thank you, Representative Mann, for introducing the bill'd like to now call on joseph kwasnik mr kwasnik you are allowed to testify and you are home thank you mr chairman can you hear me yes we can hear you i'm providing oral testimony today in support of House Bill 119.
Just to reiterate what's, I think, part of the conversation we've been having is that the authority of the PHA to oversee the pending rates and by extension of the benefit charge included in rates is specifically authorized by statute.
and is therefore the authority derived from the legislation pursuant to part one article 28 of the new hampshire constitution um also in support of of this legislation requiring legislative approval for increases in the sdc is inconsistent with long-standing legislation i would point that back in 1996, original restructuring legislation was put into place.
These provisions providing for the legislature to authorize the public utility commission to set rates and also to set benefit charges were in that original.
Clearly, the POC is better situated to evaluate the needs for increasing the system benefit charge in the new action of the general court.
Mr.
Chairman, we're having a hard time hearing the witness.
Okay, I'll speak a little up.
Can you hear me now?
Yes, thank you very much.
Thank you.
I'll start.
I won't start over, but requiring legislative approval for increases in the SBC is inconsistent, again, with longstanding legislation and the current function of the PUC to set rates and by extension the system's benefit charge.
Surely the PUC is better situated to evaluate the needs for increases in the system benefit charge than the New Hampshire General Court and can do so in an effective and timely manner.
Let's let the PUC do its job.
Also, just to remind, I have to keep reminding myself is that the legislature is a legislative body and enacts legislation.
The PUC is a regulatory body and as such is the correct authority to set rates and also enforce rates, which includes the system benefit charge.
We all have to stay within our respective legislative and regulatory guardrails.
So we hope we all keep that all in mind as you evaluate whether this bill passes or not.
Thank you for the opportunity to testify this afternoon.
Mr.
Chairman, thank you very much.
Kwasnick, any questions for Mr.
Kwasnick?
Representative Somsich, do you have a question?
Sorry, Mr.
Chairman, I didn't take my hand down.
Seeing no questions for Mr.
Kwasnick, I will thank Mr.
Kwasnick for his testimony.
And call on our next testifier, who is Madeline Minot of Clean Energy New Hampshire.
So, are you on the list here?
You are now allowed to speak, and the floor is yours.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, for the opportunity to testify on this bill.
Clean Energy New Hampshire supports House Bill 119, and I'll be speaking to this bill and then later on to the next bill, which are really about the same issue.
should the legislature or the public utilities commission review and approve changes in the system benefits charge?
I submitted written testimony to you all yesterday, so I will try to not reiterate everything that's in there.
I will also try to answer some of the questions you all have been wrestling with.
To clarify, the system benefits charge funds a significant portion of the energy efficiency programs, the energy assistance programs, as well as allows the utilities to recover loss-based revenues.
The energy efficiency programs are also funded in part by RGGI auction revenues, as well as capacity market revenues.
But the system benefits charge represents the vast majority of the funding for the energy of revenues as well as capacity market revenues.
But the system benefits charge represents the vast majority of the funding for the energy efficiency programs.
It is our view that the system benefits charge is a utility rate, just like all other utility rates.
The PUC is best equipped to review and approve those.
The PUC has the time, the expertise to properly evaluate all the details of the programs that must be reviewed, analyzed, and understood to determine if a proposed system benefits charge change is just and reasonable and would generate a net benefit for rate payers.
There is ample opportunity for public input in the Public Utilities Commission's processes to weigh in on proposed rate changes, be it a rate case where they're going to change your distribution charge or the system benefits charge.
We have concerns that legislative approval due to the legislative schedule could cause significant delays and potential suspension in the programs, which would cause interruptions in contractors' workflow and cause them to have to lay off some of their staff.
And to answer your previous question, Representative Vos, about why do we need energy efficiency programs if energy efficiency is so great?
Well, there's a few reasons.
Customers respond to price signals and incentives.
The upfront cost can be significant and difficult to overcome for many, even though the payback can be quite short.
There's a lack of information.
The energy efficiency programs offer low-cost energy audits, and you don't really know where to start, which measures to undertake, or what the payback will be without the information provided by an energy audit.
And finally, the benefits go far beyond the person making the energy efficiency improvement themselves.
And most people don't always act in an altruistic manner to reduce their own energy use to benefit all rate payers.
Really, most people are looking out for themselves without a program that incentivizes them to make those changes.
So for all those reasons, but primarily because we think the system benefits charge is a utility rate that is best reviewed and approved at the Public Utilities Commission.
We support House Bill 119 and urge you to support it as well.
Thank you.
Questions for Ms.
Minow?
Representative Oxen.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair, for taking my question.
Ms.
Minow, you mentioned that people needed energy audit in order to know what they need and what they can do and what funds might be available to help a portion of their investment.
Could you explain how did the energy audit get into this conversation?
Representative Vose has asked, if energy efficiency is so great, why do people don't just do it on their own, right?
As a homeowner, you could say, oh, great, well, I'm going to do these incentives.
Why do we need NH saves?
And why do we need the utilities to get involved?
Why do we need rebates and incentives?
And one of the four reasons I gave is that there's a lack of information for homeowners or business owners or building owners as to how to identify and prioritize potential energy efficiency measures and what the payback of an investment on those measures would be that you don't know unless an energy audit is done or a professional evaluates your energy use, your current equipment, your current building envelope.
And so that's an important service that is offered by our energy efficiency programs.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Next up is Representative Mayer.
I forget to unmute.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, the auditor is quite a variety of things.
So in Massachusetts, my daughter's house, he just walked in, he had a box full of CFLs and he went and changed all the bulbs in the house.
Then he walked around, looked at the attic and then he wrote a little contract.
And, you know, this is what it's going to cost.
It's what your benefit is going to be.
And it's a yes or no.
And it was really clear, a more complicated one.
We have a big stone library in our in our town.
We had a very experienced auditor to go up.
She had a blower door that would suck air out of the building so that, you know, where there were leaks.
You could see with an infrared camera, which she also had.
She calculated the amount of BTUs going up the stack.
I mean, it was a complete technical audit.
So they range between those two things.
And it generally sets the price and describes what to do.
We did have, I do have an experience with a local community action agency that was given a thumb rule on how to do energy efficiency.
And that is you seal the basement, you seal the attic so there won't be a flow of air up through the house.
That made the house unlivable because the furnace was sucked so much air and it had no way to get it out of the cellar.
It had to get it out through the living spaces in the house and the house leaked like a sieve and we never got it up above 50 and the tenant left in January.
So you do need an auditor that understands the subtleties of And you get it free with NH saves.
And you get it free with a mass save too, of course.
Okay.
Next up is Representative Somsich.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Ms.
Minow, for taking my question.
In light of the fact that the energy audit is really the first step, do you have any idea of how many households or residents actually have participated in energy audits for their homes, either a percentage or the numbers?
Any rough idea?
I'm sorry, I don't have those numbers off the top of my head.
There are numbers of participants for each programs in the NHSAVE's larger programs.
So when we're talking about weatherization and energy audits, that's the Home Performance with Energy Star program.
That's the Fuel Neutral Weatherization program.
There's also the HEA program, which is the income qualified programs.
So there are many different programs for many different types of customers.
There's also commercial industrial programs.
So we would have to, I'd have to understand a little bit more exactly which program and then we'd have to add up all the past participants, but it is a significant number, certainly.
Dr.
Follow up?
Follow up.
Dr.
Well, then the question asked a little differently.
Do you feel that there is still a large potential for energy gains if more people made use of the energy audits?
Or have we already exhausted most of these?
There's a tremendous amount of energy efficiency potential left in New Hampshire.
New Hampshire was the last state in New England to adopt an energy efficiency resource standard, and we've been quite far behind.
As part of the 2021 to 2023 energy efficiency resource standard planning process, which was done over the last year in a public process at the Public Utilities Commission, that plan is still pending before the commission, there was an energy efficiency potential study done by the utilities, by a consultant of the utilities, and they identified that there is in fact a tremendous amount of potential energy efficiency gains that are very cost effective to be achieved here in New Hampshire to benefit all rate payers.
And that potential study recommended much higher energy savings goals than what ended up being proposed as a middle of the road approach.
So we certainly have much left to gain and could be more aggressive on energy efficiency.
Thank you, Representative.
Thank you.
You're recognizing our question.
Yes, thank you, Chair.
Thank you, Ms.
Gonneau, for taking my question.
Earlier, you had mentioned that you equated the system's benefit charge to a utility charge, a utility cost.
And I just want to make sure that I'm understanding this correctly.
Utility costs, obviously you all have the, QC has the authority to regulate these utility monthly tangible charges.
But for this, this is a program.
This isn't a monthly utility expense.
This is actually a program.
Am I clear on that?
It is a program run by the utilities to benefit rate payers.
Yes.
Right, but it is not the same as a monthly...
I'm sorry, Chair.
I didn't have to follow up.
That's quite all right.
Go ahead and follow up.
Right, but I just want to make sure it is, as you're stating before, it is not equivalent to a monthly utility charge that you have the authority to alter and change as the demand and a lot of complicated factors go into as far as the day-by-day utility costs.
This is a program.
It is a program that is just as complicated as a utility rate case.
And unlike when your distribution charge goes up for the same service you've always gotten, if we increase energy efficiency gains, you're getting a net benefit.
And so it is a utility rate.
It is a cost on your utility bill that is administered and run by the utilities in New Hampshire, which we believe is best reviewed, evaluated, and approved by the Public Utilities Commission.
Representative Thomas is recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
just to be clear uh mr no are you saying that the electric utility companies are the ones responsible for putting this up for watching this program and getting the money and keeping it?
Or are you saying that the state has mandated and required this electric utility companies to run this program and because they're regulated, they'll do whatever the policy tells them to.
But it's really they're doing it because the state has mandated them to actually run it.
Is that correct?
Representative, you may want to ask the utilities how they feel about being the program administrators.
But I can tell you that in all of the meetings that I attend, they defend their they very strongly defend wanting to remain the program administrators for the energy efficiency programs in New Hampshire.
It has been discussed in other states, you know, Efficiency Vermont or Efficiency Maine are separate nonprofits that administer the efficiency programs.
Our utilities have fought back vehemently against even mentioning that potential idea.
So it is my understanding that they very much want to be running these programs.
They also receive a performance incentive for effectively running the programs.
They've done a good job.
And my understanding is that they would like to keep doing that.
Thank you.
But that wasn't quite the question I asked.
So I'll ask it again.
Did the electric utility companies initiate this program?
Or did the state mandate this program and ask utilities if they would run it, therefore they don't mind running it at all?
Which one was it?
You know, the initial energy efficiency core programs certainly predate my involvement in in New Hampshire policy.
So I'm not sure exactly how the core program started.
So I will not answer that question.
Follow up.
Okay, well, thank you.
So again, my question would be is if there was, let's say a limit as to the amount of SBC charges that the PUC could regulate to their liking, do you feel that there should be a limit and if a limit is therefore reached that the legislature that the legislature should therefore enact additional policy, whether to extend it or not to that degree of control?
If the legislature wishes to resort back to the core program, which is what it sounds like what you're describing, when we made the shift from the way efficiency programs used to be run in New Hampshire, which was there was a specific limited budget allocated to efficiency, and then the utilities did what they could with that budget.
That's a completely fundamentally different approach than an energy efficiency resource standard, which aims to first determine what the energy savings goals should be, and then what are the best programs to achieve those goals, and then what is the cost with a positive cost-benefit analysis to do to achieve those.
and our current statewide energy strategy says that it should be the policy of the state to achieve all cost- energy efficiency.
That is best achieved through an energy efficiency resource standard.
So it is up to the legislature to decide if you want to completely change the approach and putting budgets first, that's different.
We would be resorting back to what New Hampshire used to do.
However, in order to approve the SBC under the current model, reviewing every detail of the programs would be necessary.
And I don't think that the legislature has the time to delve into that in the detail that is necessary.
That's why I think it would be more appropriate for the Public Utilities Commission to do that.
Okay, thank you.
Next up is Representative McGee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
My question actually goes along with that because I waited a little while, so you sort of delved into this, but my understanding is that the purpose of the Public Utilities Commission is to allow those deep dives so we can be a little more strategic about how we do things.
So my question is, how well does the Public Utilities Commission rate setting process work?
Or can you give us some insights into the...
You have mentioned some of the things that they would do in the course of rate setting, but I know that you participate in those hearings and you have a lot more experience than we do.
So I guess the question is, do you think the legislature would be able to replicate the processes that the PUC undertakes in order to determine whether the rates should or should not be raised?
No, I think the legislature doesn't.
The PUC has a full staff of utility analysts.
They also have access to expert consultants, which assists them in evaluating the details of proposed plans and rates.
the efficiency docket that we just completed which is still awaiting an order lasted from September to December but it followed an almost year-long planning process that led to the filing made in September.
The docket that we just completed included roughly 28 hours of hearings.
That's following multiple tech sessions, following multiple hours of settlement negotiations between the parties.
There is an opportunity to intervene for organizations like ours.
Really anyone that has an interest may intervene.
There is also ample public comment that is submitted and considered in the dockets.
And follow up?
Follow up.
Thank you.
that is submitted and considered in the dockets and follow-up follow-up thank you um and uh i didn't write down my question um oh and so is one of the components this is my understanding so we should raise this point as well because i think it's been mentioned already, but it's important, is that one of the components of the considerations of these dockets is part of the mission of the PUC is to make sure that it's the least cost benefit for the people, the citizens of New Hampshire, right?
So there's a component of it where they're already looking at whether it's a good deal.
We don't have to keep policing the good deal because that's their mission.
Is that correct?
Absolutely.
You know, every decision that the commission makes has to be in the public interest, and they have to find that any charges to customers are just and reasonable.
And the energy efficiency programs, which are funded by the system benefits charge, every dollar that goes into the programs has to pass a very stringent cost benefit test that shows that the benefits for rate payers are greater than the program costs.
And I shared with you with my written testimony yesterday, a bill impact analysis, because I know representative asked often, well, what about the people who pay into the program and don't participate?
And that bill impact analysis shows for exactly shows participants, non-participants and average customers.
And so in many cases, even non-participants get a net benefit from what, on their bill, from what they pay into the programs.
Thank you.
Next up, we have one more person who would like to testify by the way on this bill if you'd like to hold your questions until that person testifies or not representative man do you need to ask a question right now or would you prefer to wait oh sorry no i don't i'm all set okay thank you I put my hand down.
I testify then is Kathy Corkery representing the New Hampshire Sierra Club.
and why did you disappear up okay Okay.
Ms.
Clark, you are up.
Hello.
Good afternoon.
Thank you so much, Chairman Vose, for allowing me to speak.
I had some, I originally had some trouble signing in and your records may show that I signed in opposing this bill and I would like to correct that and say that New Hampshire Sierra Club supports this bill, Hb 119 and um that we feel that politicizing rate making um is not a really good precedent um that these are complicated issues not to say that any of you cannot grasp what's going on.
Certainly you can, but there is timeliness and lots of input from the utilities and the public that the PUC allows for that goes beyond the calendar of the legislature and that it's very thorough and that these programs are very beneficial to everyone in New Hampshire.
I got my Unitel bill today and I last month was charged 89 cents for the systems benefit charge and I'm and I'm I think that's kind of important to show that every penny counts in these kinds of programs.
That it doesn't take a lot to lift the elephant, as they say, when there are many hands.
And I really think this is a great program that doesn't need to be politicized.
And I applaud the sponsors of this bill for putting it in.
Thank you.
Oh, and I apologize.
My name is Catherine Corkery.
I'm the chapter director of New Hampshire Sierra Club.
Thank you, Ms.
Corkery, for your testimony.
Nice to hear your voice again.
It's ironic that you mentioned your electric bill.
I just looked at my January electric bill as well.
I'm a New Hampshire electric co-op member, and I paid $5.89 for the system benefits charge in January.
You might need to dip into that program, sir, if I might suggest.
It's a really great one.
In the previous month.
So, thank you.
Any questions for Ms.
Corcoran?
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Seeing none, I will close the public hearing on HB 119 by pointing out that the blue list featured 22 people signed in in support four people signed in in opposition including john potichick representative potichick uh patuchick representative mcwilliams signed in in support representative amin signed in an opposition and a citizen named Alex I'd sign in in in support representative amin signed in an opposition and a citizen named alex wide signed in in opposition the sierra club get moved over into the support column as as ms corkery requested pardon ms corkery mentioned that she had an error signed up in opposition and she wanted it to be recorded that she was in support.
And I just wondered if in the numbers of 23 pro and four against, maybe that should be 24 pro and three against.
I recorded her on the testimony sheets.
It was recorded.
Thank you very much.
We will open the public hearing on HB 351.
And the prime sponsor of that bill is Representative Harrington.
So Representative Harrington, you have the floor to introduce your bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'm not going to waste a lot of time going over system benefit charges because we just spent the last hour, an hour and a half on that.
So what the bill does is two things, basically.
The first is to say it makes the system benefit charge something that we use to benefit the system.
This is the way it always used to be.
It was always used for energy efficiency programs that reduced electric consumption.
Back some time, in fact, I was actually on the commission when this happened, the utilities basically said, we got so much money and we don't have enough projects to save electricity.
So we want to start using it on thermal projects, which was allowed.
I think that was a mistake I made at the time.
If you want to benefit the system, you benefit the system.
And putting an insulation in someone's house who has oil heat does almost no savings on their electric bill.
So the concept that somehow everybody's getting a benefit from someone else's house being insulated just isn't true.
If you really feel that there's a need to subsidize insulation projects, then you should be putting a tax, because that's what it is, a tax on oil, a tax on natural gas, a tax on wood.
That's what you're saving on.
You're saving on the consumption of those things.
You're not saving on the consumption of electricity.
So that's the first part.
And the second part, it makes it clear that only the legislature or the fiscal committee shall have the authority to increase the system benefits charge.
Now, we've heard a lot of discussion here today about it being a rate case issue.
And I'll have to say, I'm going to guess, I could be wrong, but I'm going to guess I'm the only one in the room or on the phone that's actually been involved in a rate case that's on this committee.
And rate cases are extremely complicated, and they take weeks and weeks and weeks to go through with all sorts of witnesses and so forth.
This is not, the system benefit charge is nowhere near on that level of complication.
It's a, you come up with it and say, this is how much we're going to spend.
And you evaluate what the results you got from the year before.
And if they, if people feel as though, well, this is working so great, we need to change it.
They can easily come back to the legislature and bump it up.
That's the way it should be done, because it is like a tax, and the legislature should be making those decisions.
So, you know, the other thing, the one thing I wanted to stress on the first part of there, again, is this concept that everybody benefits.
There may be other things you want to look at, because you're because less oil is being burned or less natural gas is being consumed.
But that doesn't do anything to save someone money on their electric bill.
The only person that benefits that is the recipient.
So I don't think we should be using it.
It was never done that way up until a few years ago.
And we should go back to spending the system benefit charge to benefit the system.
And I'll be glad to take any questions.
Thank you, Representative Harrington.
and I'll see glad to take any questions.
I have a question for you.
The system benefits charge is a separate charge on the electric bill, but if energy efficiency provides great benefits to the energy system itself, should energy efficiency charges actually be built into the rates that utilities, both gas and electric, charge their customers?
Well, that's a very good point, Mr.
Chairman.
In fact, it's an area that I broached with a few people over the last few months in that it's a real quantum shift in how we do things.
With the system benefit charge right now, we basically collect money and then we put it in the bucket and we hand the bucket to the utilities and say, go spend this money this year.
And they run around and try to do their best to spend all the money that's available.
And this is not small amounts of money.
We're talking tens of millions of dollars over the year, probably in the hundreds of millions now.
And so they spend that and they go out and they try to find the best projects they can.
But their goal basically is here's the amount of money you've got to spend, go find projects to meet them.
I would think a longer term fix that would work better would be if the utilities started looking at projects that was going to save electricity and then said, look, if we implement this, whatever it is we're going to implement, we can reduce the consumption of electricity over a period of time and they would get compensated to do that.
But that's sort of a different direction than what we presently have.
And that would be a major change in the program.
And I'm not proposing that at this time.
And of course, the other thing I should have mentioned is I did last year run down.
I got a bill from Eversource for Eastern Massachusetts and one for New Hampshire.
And when the same amount of electric consumption, the person in Massachusetts pays about 20 percent higher, higher bill than they do in New Hampshire.
So there's just throwing money at energy efficiency programs and more solar subsidies and so forth doesn't get you a lower electric bill.
So.
Thank you, Representative Harrington.
Do we have any further questions for Representative Harrington?
Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Harrington.
Do you think that in terms of trying to get more efficiency into our buildings and houses here in the state, do you think that we would be better served if we, if a different committee that is looked at housing codes and adjusting housing codes to build more homes?
Well, thank you for the question.
In fact, I believe that is done.
There's the state building codes that are updated on a regular basis that if you would look at the code today, for example, as compared to 25 years ago, you'd find that the requirements for insulation and et cetera are much, much higher than they were.
So most of what we're dealing with here is the retrofitting existing buildings that have been around for some time.
I don't think there's too much of the core money that's going to, at least on residential properties for new construction.
It may be, I just can't remember that level of detail on the program, if it is actually used in, like if someone was to build a factory or something, could they get money from it?
I just don't know.
But basically, the codes are updated to be much more energy efficient than they were in the past.
Follow up.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Representative Harrington.
And am I to assume that these updated codes, would they also be applying to any housing renovations that are being done, even though they're old houses?
I'm not sure about that because most of the code applications come in if you have to get a building permit.
And certain things require a building permit and certain things don't.
And if you have a building permit, then I would assume there's going to be some new requirements put in.
Or if you hire, I mean, unlike other states in New Hampshire, you can do your own electrical and plumbing work.
But if you hire a professional, I know that they may say, hey, I can only put it into the newest code.
So I'm going to upgrade it if you want me to do the work.
But I don't think that's the same for installation because I don't I don't believe those people licensed by the state.
Thank you.
Thank you representative Harrington I have another question for you.
Back in 2001 2002 Dutch economist Arthur van Blentham did a pioneering study on energy efficiency where he compared the gdp of about 70 different countries to their expenditures on energy efficiency and he was surprised to discover that spending money on energy efficiency kind of had the opposite effect of what he expected what he discovered was that if you save somebody $5 on their electric bill, rather than spending that on groceries or buying a new sweater or spending it on a new pair of shoes, people would instead go out and buy a new electrical device and use more electricity because they thought they were using it more efficiently.
Do you think that that kind of behavior still happens in the country here today and in our state?
Well, I certainly would think it would to some extent, but again, you've got to look at the fact that I think at this point, especially in residential properties, the majority of the money that's being used from the system benefit charge is going for thermal insulation projects to save on heating costs.
So it's not going to have an effect on their electric bill one way or the other.
And I think that generally with most people, if you get, let's just say you have a bill of $120 every month for electricity and you get some new, I don't know, a new refrigerator or you go to all sorts of LED lights or whatever and that drops to $110.
Yeah, probably you might spend another $10 to buy something that you wouldn't have otherwise and plug it into the wall.
The, you know, the thing you're going to remember about this, all these energy efficiency projects is that the most efficient use of spending money is when someone spends their own money.
When you're spending somebody else's money, you're never as careful.
I don't care how hard the bureaucrats or the people at the utilities try.
They're never going to be as careful as when you're spending your own money.
And if all these projects are so worthwhile, people would be willing to spend their own money.
It seems like more of an education issue from what I'm hearing that they said one of the ladies who spoke early was saying that she didn't think people were aware of it.
Well, I know when we were at the PUC that there was a program where people could get renewable energy, up to 100% renewable energy.
And the utilities spent a lot of time and effort pushing that.
And they actually ended up doing surveys of people and they found out well they didn't want to spend more for the renewable energy because they didn't want to spend more for energy period so I just think that's something you need to always remember here if a project is really a good idea and it's going to save money over a reasonable amount of time then people will do it and they could be convinced of doing it but when you're spending somebody else's money you're never as efficient as when you're spending your own.
Thank you Representative Homeless recognized for a question.
Yes sir thank you.
Yes Representative Harrington thanks for taking my question.
We had heard testimony prior that some of these SBS I'm sorry, excuse me.
i'm having a little trouble hearing you oh i'm sorry we started sliding over there a little bit more thank you is that better yes it is thank you thank you so much um we've heard that uh the systems benefit charge is is complex in the prior testimony and that's why it was recommended that the PUC be the ones that has the time to do the hard work on that.
And you had mentioned just a few minutes ago that it was actually a bit of a simpler process than being advertised.
I'm just wondering if you can give an example of that.
Thank you.
Sure.
Thanks for the question.
Well, like I say, a rate case is something that people don't understand.
A full-blown rate case, for example, is something that's only done every five or six years.
It's not like they, because rates change, that doesn't mean there's a full-blown rate case.
Full-blown rates case takes weeks of hearings, weeks of meetings, flying in experts from here, there, and everywhere, it seems like.
And it's a very, very long, drawn out technical process.
System benefit charge is simply a matter of saying, how much do we want to spend on low income assistance or how much we want to spend on energy efficiency projects?
It's a it's a it's a basically a quantitative number you come up with say, well, that's about the right amount let's spend that and see what happens and then of course you know as you build up some history on this maybe that amount gets adjusted but it's not that complicated to come up with it you can make it whatever you want and see how it works nothing like a rate case whatsoever not even close thank you thank you uh next step up is Representative Cretiens is recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
I just wanted to clarify about something that you said earlier about comparing New Hampshire versus Massachusetts, and you were saying the rate on the same amount of energy is higher in Massachusetts.
Is that accurate?
Well, not exactly, but the bill itself, so that includes the energy portion, the distribution, the transmission, and any other sundry charges that they have on their bill, like we have our system benefit charge and so forth.
So if you use 650 kilowatt hours, which is what we take as an average in a month, and you live in eastern Massachusetts, your total bill would be about 20% higher.
I think that was the last I checked than it is in New Hampshire.
So I think that's really the incorrect comparison.
If you're talking about energy efficiency investments being correct, wouldn't you want to look at the same size house and see what Thank you.
comparison, if you're talking about energy efficiency investments being correct, wouldn't you want to look at, you know, the same size house and see what their bill is versus the same number of kilowatt hours?
You're holding that study.
Well, you could go on and make that study to be, you know, look at every house individually in the state and figure out what the cubic area was inside of it and et cetera, how many windows it had, whether it was south facing and north facing, if you're working about heat or how many, you know, how much.
I'm just saying that's that's if you take a typical bill and that's what we that's the figure what's been used for years or is it 650 meg kilowatt hours it would be about 20 percent higher in Massachusetts.
That's if you take a typical bill, and that's the figure that's been used for years, or is it 650 kilowatt hours, it would be about 20% higher in Massachusetts than it is in New Hampshire.
I realize that's not a perfect analogy on everything, but it's the best one I have right now.
But if the point of energy efficiency is to reduce that number?
Remember, Representative Cretchen.
Sorry.
I apologize.
I just was concerned I wasn't getting my answer.
All right, but never let it happen again.
Sorry, can I ask a second question?
Follow up, yes, as long as it's a question.
Sure.
Theorizing, if you are somebody who makes $30,000 a year and needs to spend their money on food, does that not also play into your decision of whether it's worth investing in energy efficiency versus if you're someone who makes $200,000 and has a lot more disposable income to invest?
I'm sure it does.
Okay.
Just wanted to make sure we were on the same page there.
Thank you.
Next up would be Representative McGee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'd like to point you, Representative Harrington, to the section of your bill that's on line 13, because you had answered a question in testimony saying that the system benefits charge in terms of utility rate setting is a lot simpler than a full blown rate case, which might take weeks.
But this section here says that there would be an exemption for a three year energy plan that was arrived at through a full-blown process over at the Public Utilities Commission, which was just completed in December.
And you've removed that here from the bill so that basically that full-blown process where they did an entire analysis and came up with a plan that they would like to support with the system benefits charge, which is supposed to be exempt from oversight, as you suggest through your prior language in the bill, you're basically taking that out as well.
So I hope you could speak to that because I don't think you should be taking that out here.
I think that that exception that says that a three-year energy efficiency resource standard framework that's been established by order for 2016, 2020, and 23 should go forward basically without, you know, being delayed in any way.
So I'm wondering why you took that language out.
I took it out basically because I don't think that that's the right group to be doing this.
I think that the legislature should have the authority to raise what effectively is a tax on electric consumption.
And there's nothing wrong with the study.
If the legislature decided that's a great guideline, whatever that came out to be, let's put it in statute and we'll follow it.
I'd have no problem with looking into that.
But I'm saying that the authority to do that should be with the legislature and not with the PUC.
It's a matter of a philosophy of how we govern.
No, I understand it's a philosophy.
May I have a follow-up, Mr.
Chairman?
Follow-up, make sure it's a question, please.
Yeah, yeah.
I guess the question really is, though, that you just testified that the complex stuff is stuff that you would, this is not complex stuff, but this exception relates to a complex process that was undertaken in order to thoroughly understand what was going to be done with that money.
What I'm saying is, do you see the legislature as being able to replicate what they just underwent in order to figure out whether it was a good thing to go forward with a three-year plan that everybody could rely on?
No, not at all.
I don't think that's the issue.
I think you're missing my point here.
It's not that we can't have the PUC do studies on whatever.
It's just that when it comes to putting a tax on the electric bill, which is this, that should be done by the legislature.
Now, they can do that by saying, just like we do in many other bills in many other departments, you know, the Department of Environmental Services, so study the whatever, whatever, whatever, fill in the blank and report back to the legislature with a recommendation for lead limits on drinking water.
The same thing could be done here, but the legislature should retain the authority to put that into effect because it's a tax.
Well, we've had other testimony that it was a utility rate.
So I just, that's confusing.
I think in your mind, it's a tax, but yeah.
Okay.
Thanks.
May I suggest that since it is 422 and we have 11 more people signed up to speak on this bill, that we move on and hold questions until the next speaker would that be satisfactory to everyone okay in that case i will call on the next speaker who is mari brunner a member of the public who represents the staff of the city of keene Thank you.
Hi, thank you so much.
I'll keep my comments really brief.
I mostly wanted to log in today to learn more about this bill and hear what the hearing was like.
I am the planner for the city of Keene and I work with the city's energy and climate committee and that committee has spent a lot of time over the past couple of years working with a local group to help promote the New Hampshire Energy Saves program.
So I mostly logged in today because I was concerned that this bill might take funding away from that program.
I think it's had a lot of value to the citizens of Keene.
We recently held a workshop right before COVID hit actually that was very well attended with over 50 attendees.
And a lot of different households got their energy audit done as a result of that.
So I'm mostly here today in opposition to this bill, concerned that it might affect the New Hampshire Saves program.
So thank you.
That's all I had to say.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Any questions for Ms.
Brenner?
Representative Cretien, you have a question?
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
My hand was still at the left hand.
OK, we'll move on to our next speaker.
Next speaker I had on the list was Dorothy Currier.
However, I do not see her on the list of the attendees list.
So I'm going to skip this Currier and move to the next speaker, who would be Anna Blake.
Is she on the list?
No, she doesn't appear to be on the list.
I wonder why people sign up if they don't.
Okay, so we'll move to the next person on the list, who would be Peter Hansel.
And he is here, so Mr.
Hansel, you are up.
Thank you.
Hopefully you can hear me.
I am from Keene.
I'm actually, I work with Mary Brunner on the Energy and Climate Committee for Keene.
I'm not speaking as a chairman of that committee, but I am very concerned as a private citizen in Keene.
And my hope is that you will keep all forms of energy in the language that is before you because we believe that energy is all related.
And let me give you an example.
Many residences and businesses have multiple forms of energy, and reducing any of those through energy efficiency measures will ultimately affect the other energy needs.
as described in our recently passed sustainable energy plan in Keene, we're trying to help our community, our city, residents, as well as the municipal sector, residents and businesses transition to 100% renewable energy over the next decades in the future.
Part of the strategy of doing that is to help them conserve energy, because that's the best way to start any kind of transition process is through conservation.
And if you're looking at a typical example of a house in Keene, it may be an older housing stock.
We have a lot of older houses in Keene with possibly oil heating.
And one way to start the transition process towards renewable energy is to help them save energy through weatherization or other energy saving methods, even if they're oil-heated.
Gradually, over time, they're going to transition away from oil heat towards something else.
And at this point, with the current technology, the most efficient way to do that is towards electrical heat, either through a heat pump of some sort or some other form.
And ultimately, the energy they save now in reducing their energy heating needs is going to save them not only construction costs in conversion to a different form of energy, but also in daily operational costs as they go down the road with their electrical heat pumps.
So that's just an example.
Businesses face the same thing.
I am recently retired from a business that used primarily oil heat, but several years ago made the transition towards a biomass, a wood chip boiler, with the help of some incentives that we got through the New Hampshire Saves Program.
So I just want to emphasize that keeping all forms of energy in this bill is important and will ultimately save electrical use in the long term.
One other comment on the system's benefits charge, if you can keep that as stable as possible, it allows and not make it something subject to partisan changes regularly.
It makes it easier for a contractor to plan for getting it, whether or not to get into that business.
We could use a lot more energy auditors, energy contractors in our region.
We have to go all the way over to the other part of the state to bring in people who are certified here.
And one way to encourage that is to make this, the sustainable benefits charge as stable as possible and keep the politics out of it as much as possible.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you very much for your testimony.
Do you need to ask a question, Representative Somsich?
Yes, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for asking.
Because you touched on this, I think Representative Harrington touched on this earlier too, about the fact that the energy efficiency measures don't just benefit the electric bill, but also provides efficiencies for other fuels.
Would it be your understanding that you would like to see the energy efficiency measures be applied also for people who use either electricity, oil, gas, or wood to heat their homes?
I think the way that it's applied, thank you for asking that question, I think the way that it is applied currently, where they give the New Hampshire Saves Program has the option of making energy efficiency, regardless of whether it's for electricity or oil or propane or whatever is correct, because I think they're all related.
Okay, Senator Thomas is recognized for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Hansel for taking my question.
You mentioned a desire to keep the SBC stable.
Would you be in favor of saying having a set price for the SBC and maybe it doesn't get touched for five or 10 years down the future so so it stays the same.
I am not an expert on that.
All I know is from my perspective, the more that we can spend on energy conservation, the better.
What I would not like to see is it cut, cut, and then added, and then cut, and then added, depending on what legislatures empoweratures in power at the time.
I think the more stability is desired and possibly increase it as time goes on.
Thank you.
You absolutely need to ask a question, Representative McGee, or can we move on to the next speaker?
I do have a question.
I do have a question for the speaker.
Thank you Mr.
Hansel.
You said that you're involved with the city of Keene I believe?
I'm on the energy and climate committee for the city of Keene yes..
Yes.
And I understand that my, my town also has an energy committee that's very active.
And I wondered if you could say anything about how Keene got started on that.
Cause I understand that actually a lot of towns are undertaking their efforts towards net zero by 2050 or whatever goals they're trying to meet because of state initiatives that asked them to undertake that planning.
Is that not correct?
Not to my knowledge.
I'm not familiar with that from a state point of view.
I know that Keene got started way back in 2004, I think, some time back there, when we joined the Cities for Climate Protection, which was a national initiative.
And out of that grew our committee.
We recently changed that committee name from Cities for Climate Protection to our Energy and Climate Committee.
And I think we are proud of the leadership role that we've taken in the state in taking some of these initiatives.
We also have a Community Power Aggregate Committee that's actively trying to get a community power program started in Keene as part of our energy plan.
Okay, thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
I'd like to point out that we have seven more speakers who would like to speak on this bill, and we will be leaving.
We will be closing this public hearing and leaving no later than five o'clock.
The reports coming in from the weather south of us indicate that there is fairly heavy snow building up.
So for people who have to drive home, we want to get them out of here and an hour that allows them to get home.
And a decent hour themselves.
So next up, provided I can find her on the list here, is Emily Manns, a member of the public.
But I do not see her, so we move on to the next speaker after that who is Mr.
Chair could you ask Mari Bruner and Peter Hansel to mute now that they've completed their testimony we're getting echo at least I am I'm getting an echo through the system.
Okay.
I'll take care.
Donna Reardon.
Is there a Donna Reardon who would like to speak?
I have a Donna here with no last name.
I will allow her to speak and hope that she is Donna Reardon.
Go ahead and speak.
Don't forget to unmute yourself.
You know, one of the Donnas has a last name, but this one doesn't.
But apparently she is not there.
So we will move on.
Next up would be the other Donna, Donna Gamache.
Hey Donna.
So we just allow Donna to speak.
And Ms.
Gamache, you are on.
Thank you very much.
Nice to see as many of you that I can see.
Thanks very much for the opportunity to provide some comments this afternoon.
For the record, I'm Donna Gamache, Director of Government Affairs for Eversource Energy.
And if it's at all possible, I also wanted to introduce Kate Peters, who runs these programs for Eversource, these energy efficiency programs.
And she has expertise.
She could say a few words in a few minutes, but also answer any of your questions that you have that are specific to the programs, if that's okay.
But I'll be very, very brief before that.
You've heard enough today about how and when this legislature created the system benefits charge to do two things, to provide payment assistance to low-income customers and for programs to assist customers in lowering their electric usage.
The programs started out very small and have evolved over the years as new technology has become available and as our customers' needs have developed and then also policy priorities have changed.
We're proud to have come this far, and we continue to participate in rigorous reviews by our regulator, the Public Utilities Commission, and we also look forward to, this is just, this is sort of in my closing, we're looking forward to working with you um the sponsor and the committee to see if we could all find a way to ensure that we could come up with some language that provides the transparency um that you're all looking for that is appropriate which we think is appropriate um with a view on the programs the benefits and the costs so in a way that doesn't slow down these programs.
So anyway, I just wanted to say that we're committed to trying to bridge the bridge between the two and we're happy to be creative and come up with something.
But with that, if it's okay, I'd love to turn it over to Kate Peters, if you don't mind, Mr.
Chairman, if that'd be possible.
Yes, that's okay.
Thank you.
She's going to use your microphone or do I have to?
I think she has to be unmuted.
She's there, but I can't.
We're not in the same room, unfortunately.
I'm sorry to give you this issue.
I did not intend for that.
I see her now.
Okay.
Ms.
Peters, you are on.
Hello.
Thank you so much.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Thank you.
Just a couple additions to what Donna had to say.
I think we always, when we are writing plans and going before the commission, want to understand and make sure that we are following the state's policy priorities, which the legislature sets.
And to the extent that we can understand those priorities before and while we are writing the plan, rather than kind of writing the plan and doing all the work to develop it and then coming back afterwards for potential changes in direction.
I think that's where some of the administrative difficulties that others have been talking about come.
It creates uncertainty.
So it's very helpful for us to know what we are aiming to do as we are developing it rather than having that potentially changed after we've developed it.
I did also want to note that the fuel neutral aspects of our program where we're doing weatherization for fuel oil and propane, we've been doing that for our low-income customers since 2001.
That is the primary energy use in those low-income customers' homes, and to provide benefit for them and reduce their use of other fuel heating subsidies, that's been seen as a priority, I think, by a wide variety of policymakers and regulators.
We've been providing those weatherization services for our kind of standard residential customers, not low income, since 2012.
So for many years now, there's a contractor base of 20 to 30 small businesses in the state that do this work.
They are, for the most part, small businesses owned by individuals.
They employ several hundred employees across the state in well-paying and skilled jobs to do this weatherization work.
And so I think there would be some pretty big impacts if we were to shift away from being able to provide those services.
And they're also very well desired by our customers.
These are very popular programs with our residential customers.
We do balance them out with significant efforts to reduce electricity use.
As Representative Harrington said, that is our primary goal for the programs our commercial programs focus on that almost exclusively but the fuel neutral aspect there has been a very important part for our residential customers so i just wanted to provide a little more background on that and i've heard a couple questions that that i could probably speak to but i i don't want to presume and so i'll leave it there.
And if you have any questions that I could answer, I will happily do so.
Thank you, Ms.
Peters.
Does anybody have a burning question for Ms.
Peters or Ms.
Kamash?
Representative Kelly Vitz, don't forget to unmute.
I don't know if it's a burning question, but I would like to ask Ms.
Peters, in this time of COVID, in just these nine months, do you know if your requests have gone up because people are having a more difficult time?
Yes, that's a great question.
So in 2020, we actually saw more demand from our residential customers.
We overachieved our residential goals because people were at home.
They were thinking about their energy use at home.
They were interested in projects that they could do to improve their homes.
We saw in 2020 more difficulty for some of the business customers who were dealing with a lot of different scenarios and sometimes their priorities were focused in other areas.
But we are seeing some strong demand from commercial customers going into 2021 as they're all anticipating kind of how they're gonna manage their future business plans.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.
Any additional questions?
Seeing none, we will now move on.
Whoops.
There is one.
Representative Harrington is recognized for a question.
I think I'm unmuted.
Yeah.
This is from Ms.
Gamache.
What is the estimate for the total spending for the core fund for this year?
How many millions?
You know, that's why I brought Kate here because she's closer to the numbers.
Would you mind if I handed that over to Kate to answer?
Absolutely not.
Thank you.
So right now we are on a continuation of the 2020 budget levels for the programs.
And I actually don't have it right in front of me, but I believe it is around $63 million.
That's for all the utilities combined, not just Eversource.
All right, thank you.
Okay, Representative Oxum.
Thank you very much.
Ms.
Peters, could you help me with the other aspect?
You've done a great job for us.
Thank you so much in talking've been talking about how the benefits to the customer who actually gets the upgrade.
But I had the larger interest, which goes to the fact that we get payments from the forward capacity market also for energy efficiency, because we're reducing peak demand, peak demand being such a costly part of our of our bills and really driving the cost, because that's the moment at which we have to pay the highest prices.
Could you speak to how energy efficiency benefits everyone by reducing the peak demand?
Certainly.
So energy efficiency, reducing electric use overall does also reduce peak usage.
And so all of our standard electric reduction offerings also lower use on peak days.
We also have a set of programs called active demand programs, which are designed specifically to work with customers to reduce usage on those highest use days in the summer, where the high prices are being set for the regional market for the year.
And those have been pilots the past two years.
We've had great enrollment.
We actually were just at a meeting.
We had a wait list for Eversource commercial customers.
43, I'm sorry, we had 87 customers that wanted to participate this summer, large commercial entities.
We were only able to sign up 43 of them.
So there's more that could be done.
And when you reduce use on those peak days, you are lowering the peak needs of the system as a whole.
And so there are benefits to the system as a whole.
And that's kind of my layman's explanation of it, if that's helpful.
Follow up, Mr.
Chair?
Follow up.
Could you give us just, I know it's a ballpark estimate, but would you say that the savings when you can cut down peak demand could be in the millions of dollars?
Yes, certainly.
We looked at in our three-year plan creation, we did a study that looked at the cost requirement for the utilities.
So our overall system costs and the impact that the energy efficiency from the plan would have on those revenue requirements for the system.
And we found that there was a more than $300 million positive impact on the overall revenue requirements for the utility.
So the implementation of the efficiency measures lower the revenue requirements, the system costs for the utilities.
And the study that we did for the plan, it was the exact numbers escaping me, but it was over $300 million.
Thank you so very much.
Okay.
Thank you, Ms.
Peters.
We'd like to call on our next presenter, who is the fount of all knowledge regarding things having to do with the energy systems in the electricity sector and the Public Utilities Commission.
That is New Hampshire's own consumer advocate, Don Kreitz.
Don, you are on.
Good afternoon, everybody.
That is the most flattering and complimentary introduction I have ever received anywhere, and certainly anywhere in the halls, whether virtual or real, of the state legislature.
But I'm going to leap right into my substantive testimony.
With all due respect to my friend, Representative Harrington, with whom I go back many years, I do not agree that the system benefits charge is a tax.
It is not collected by the government.
It is not remitted to the government.
The government never has custody of the money, and the government does not spend the money.
Ergo, the system benefits charge is not a tax.
It is a rate, which is to say it is a charge approved by the Public Utilities Commission that pays for a service from utility customers to their customers.
I have a heretical thing to say about why it is better for the PUC to make this decision rather than the general court.
Your committee, House Committee on Science, Tech and Energy, has, I would contend, more expertise on it collectively than the Public Utilities Commission has.
Because I know many of you, and there is a great deal of knowledge, including the fact that you have a former PUC commissioner on the committee.
So really, it is just a matter of whether you have the time to conduct the kind of analysis that you would need to conduct.
Now, again, I have to respectfully disagree with my friend, Representative Harrington, about the complexity of the task of determining what system benefits charge is adequate to the task of paying for energy efficiency.
If you look at what the utilities filed with the PUC on September 1st in support of their triennial plan and requested SBC levels, you will see a filing that is, I believe, well in excess of 400 pages.
And most of that filing is very detailed schedules that support all the calculations that drive creating an energy efficiency resource standard that sets savings goals and establishes savings programs and provides for monitoring, evaluation and verification and sets the SBC and related gas charges at the appropriate levels.
You know, Representative Harrington referred to just throwing money at energy efficiency programs, and it really isn't true that anybody is doing any throwing of any money anywhere.
In fact, I don't know of money that is more rigorously evaluated for the cost effectiveness of its spending.
We have an excellent cost effectiveness test that we began applying here in New Hampshire at the beginning of 2020.
It requires every program in the EERS to save money for customers as a group.
So it doesn't take into account the benefits to the individual customers who get the measures installed on their premises.
Rather, it focuses on all ratepayers.
That is very important.
There were some points made about electricity bills paid by customers in Massachusetts versus electricity bills paid for by customers here in New Hampshire.
And it is true that Massachusetts is the number two state for energy efficiency, whereas New Hampshire, I believe, is number 18 now.
So we're last in the region.
But it is not fair to suggest that Massachusetts electricity bills are higher because they have such excellent energy efficiency programs.
Massachusetts also has a lot of public policy that requires purchases of renewable energy for which customers arguably pay twice in Massachusetts because of the way the regional market rules are crafted.
Now, I'm not here to analyze Massachusetts's electricity costs.
I'm just here to say that comparing them on a rote basis, on a simplistic basis, to our electricity costs is not really helpful.
Finally, I just want to say that it is not my understanding that the electric utilities were dragged kicking and screaming to the job of administering our energy efficiency programs.
Not only are they enthusiastic about it now, but I believe they were enthusiastic about it right around the turn of the century when they participated in the energy efficiency working group that came out of the restructuring settlement agreement that launched restructuring at the turn of the century.
And the utilities were strong proponents of what began as the core programs, and they are strong proponents today of the energy efficiency resource standard, which is all about setting savings goals that are appropriate, appropriately ambitious, and then making sure that we have the money to pay for them.
Beyond that, in the interest of time, I submitted written testimony earlier today.
I earnestly commend it to your reading pleasure.
Thank you, Mr.
Kreese.
We appreciate your testimony, written and verbal.
And if any members of the committee need to ask Mr.
Kreese any questions, I suggest you give him a call.
He's always available and very willing to chat with anyone.
Indeed.
We'll now call on our last speaker of the day, and that is Huck Montgomery from Liberty.
And Mr.
Montgomery, you have exactly five minutes to make your presentation.
Thank you.
That's wonderful.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Just a quick check.
Can everybody hear me okay?
Yes.
Great.
Well, thanks so much for the record.
It's Huck Montgomery.
I'm the Director of Government Affairs for Liberty Utilities.
Now going by Liberty, so you'll look for some exciting changes in our logo when you see our trucks on the road soon.
I just want to say here today that Liberty is opposed to House Bill 351.
And that really is because we stand unequivocally behind the 2021-2023 triennial plan, which is before the Public Utility Commission today, and on which they're expected to rule before the end of the month.
That plan was developed through an exhaustive collaborative process that includes robust public input, input from a diverse array of stakeholders, and was recommended to the commission unanimously by the EERS committee, which reviews it.
The plan, the settlement agreement was unanimously supported by the parties at the PUC.
And we think that the plan that is before the PUC now is a great plan.
That's going to save our customers substantial amounts of money on their bill over the long run.
It's going to be a really beneficial thing to see implemented.
And what this bill would do substantively with regard to legislative scrutiny of plans is very simply to subject the plan that was produced over the course of the last year.
And as before the Public Utilities Commission at this time for their final approval to legislative scrutiny, to the approval of the legislature.
But that's it.
Very narrowly, that's what it does.
It takes the plan that we have worked really hard on, that we are very proud of, and that was developed pursuant to current law.
And it adds a new level of approval that wasn't anticipated as the plan was being crafted.
So it's important to note that all future system benefits charge increases due to EERS, future EERS plans are already going to be subject to legislative approval according to current law.
So what we're talking about here is should the work that Kate, our energy efficiency manager, Eric Stanley, our counterparts at Unitel, and everyone has been working so hard on over the last year, which was universally recognized by the stakeholders who were involved in the creation of it, which include representatives from the business community, from the environmental community, and everywhere in between, they all really supported this and said that this is the best way for us to achieve all cost-effective energy efficiency.
We would be putting that instead before the legislature for it to sign off on, regardless of whether the PUC found that it met the requirements under the law that it was developed under.
So we urge you to reject House Bill 351.
We think that it's unnecessary.
The future EERS plans would certainly fall under legislative purview anyway.
And the plan that's before the Public Utility Commission now is a fantastic one.
Remember, all spending under that plan must be found to be cost effective by the Public Utilities Commission in that it would net more savings than you put into it.
A long-term revenue requirement reduction number, meaning what does this save you over the long run is 1.36% on your electric bill and 2.27% on your gas bill.
That's where that's going.
And we think that's a good thing.
And I would just want to reiterate as I close here that to quote Mr.
Kreese, this is actually the word that I had written down on my notes as well.
The utilities and speaking for Liberty, we are enthusiastic about being the program administrators of the utility programs here, and we're excited to see, hopefully, this EERS plan that's before the Public Utilities Commission now be implemented.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Happy to take any questions.
Thank you very much.
Unfortunately, we don't have time for any questions.
I will report that on HB 315, or 351, I should say, three people signed in to support the bill, 46 signed in to oppose the bill.
So that closes the public hearing on HB 351.
The next committee session will be on Monday, February the 8th.
The session after that will be on Friday, February the 8th.
The session after that will be on Friday, February the 19th.
So use that for your planning purposes for the upcoming couple of weeks.
It's possible we may get a date before the 19th, but as of today, the 19th was the next available date to us.
So with us.
So with that, I will- Mr.
Chairman, Mr.
Chairman, can I ask a question of you?
Reports, minority reports and other reports, they're due tomorrow.
Is that correct?
Yes, that is correct.
By what time or any particular time?
Three o'clock in the afternoon.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Mr.
Chairman also, if I may.
Yes, Mr.
Vincent.
Thank you.
So today's meeting was at 10.
And I know there was some talk that was earlier.
Is it still going to be at 10?
Our Monday meetings will start at 10 because at 9 o'clock, there's a leadership meeting that Representative Thomas and I have to go to.
That's fine, I just want clarification.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chairman.
You're very welcome.
And thank you all, have a wonderful week and we'll see you next Monday.
You too, thank you.
Drive safely, everyone.
Yes.